this comprehensive course guides you
through crafting a robust e-commerce
website similar to amazon.com using
nexjs 13.4 and its new app router Master
next.js server actions database
intricacies with Prisma seamless
authentication via next auth and mongodb
and create a stellar UI using Tailwind
CSS and Daisy UI Beyond building you'll
also dive into deploying your project on
versel optimizing metadata for each page
duplicating Prisma requests and setting
up essential tools like prettier and
eslint for a streamlined development
experience Florian Walther created this
course he is an experienced developer
and popular teacher hola Muchachos in
this tutorial we will build an amazing
e-commerce website using next.js13 to
get a ref react server components and
silver actions which are still in Alpha
right now for the styling of our website
we will use 10 a win CSS together with a
really nice component Library called
Daisy UI we will store our data in
mongodb and to connect to our database
we will use the Prisma orm which works
really nicely together with nexjs and we
will even Implement authentication into
our website so that a user can log in
and for this we will use next auth so
this is a full stack project where we
build both the front end and the back
end right in next.js and we are really
using The Cutting Edge technology right
now in this tutorial the latest of the
latest some of these features are still
in Alpha so this tutorial will really
equip you for the future if you want to
be an xjs developer okay so without
further Ado let's take a look at the
project we will be building here so our
website is called flomazon and it's a
place where you can spend all your money
and as you can see on the front page we
see the list of products available on
our eCommerce website they are ordered
in descending order with the newest
product and top and this is completely
Dynamic so this featured product here at
the top which is displayed in this large
box is not hard coded if we added a new
product to the database the new product
would be shown at the top and the pen
would be shown here as the second
product but the featured product is only
shown on the first page so if we
navigate to Page tour we don't have this
featured product at the top anymore
so we Implement pagination as well the
cool thing is the way next.js renders
and caches Pages makes them open really
fast so if I click on a product the page
is there instantly there is no loading
time because this data is pre-rendered
and then cached we can of course add
items to our cart and this is executed
in a server action server actions are a
next JS feature that's still in Alpha
right now and they are basically a way
to execute post requests on our server
like adding an item to the card as we
just did without having to set up a
separate endpoint so this happens all
directly in our components server
actions are still in Alpha right now and
you will learn how they work throughout
this tutorial let's add a few more items
to our card maybe a banana
and
the Game Boy here
we can see how many items we have in the
card and when we click on it we even see
the subtotal so the current total price
for all items we can navigate to the
cart page where we see a list of all
items in our account here we can also
change the quantity of each item similar
to how it works on Amazon and again this
is executed in a server action and when
we change the quantity of an item of
course the subtotal updates as well our
navbar updates and everything just works
now the checkout button is just the
dummy it doesn't actually do anything
when we click it I know that many of you
would like to see a tutorial with stripe
implementation but I think stripe should
be covered in a separate tutorial to not
make one tutorial too bloated with too
many different topics so if you want to
see a stripe tutorial by me then leave a
comment below if there is enough
interest I might make one and of course
leave a like on this video because only
this way I know that there's actually
more interest in tutorials like this but
I haven't shown you the coolest feature
of this project right now so I really
wanted to make the shopping cart
professional I wanted to have it work
like in a real production website like
Amazon and every professional e-commerce
website should have an anonymous
shopping cart in my example and I've
implemented this so if I sign out I
still have a shopping cart which right
now is empty because I'm not logged into
my account anymore but I can still add
items to this Anonymous shopping cart so
here comes the cool thing when I now log
into my account again which we can do
via Google login but you can also add
other authentication providers if you
want
if I log into my account which was this
one here
it now merges the anonymous shopping
cart with the shopping cart of this user
account so previously we had six items
in our shopping cart in this account but
now we have seven why because it merged
this mouse we added to the anonymous
shopping cart into this authenticated
shopping cart and now when I log out
again the anonymous shopping cart is
emptier so maybe let's repeat this one
more time to really see that this works
so remember we had seven items in our
account I add another item or let's add
tour to this Anonymous shopping cart so
now when we log into our account we
should have nine items in there right
so we log in again
it merges the shopping carts and there
are our nine items
so this is really professional also all
these pages are servers at Renault which
doesn't only make them great for SEO
search engine optimization but this also
allows us to have all the data available
when we open the web page so if I
refresh this page you will notice that
there is no moment where the shopping
cart is emptier with zero items or not
shown at all instead when we refresh the
page we see the number nine here
immediately when the page is opened and
this again in my opinion feels really
professional because there is no glitch
in the UI and this is also how it looks
on Amazon when you refresh the page
there is no loading time for the
shopping cart because we are not loading
the shopping cart client side like in a
classic react App instead we loaded
server side so the data is there as soon
as the page is visible on the screen we
even Implement a search functionality
which again is executed through server
actions so let's try this out maybe
let's search for fun let's see what we
find we are searching in the title and
in the description of the product so
somewhere in here is probably word fun
let's also search for pen I know that we
have at least one pen there's our pen
and somewhere in here is the word pen as
well but you can fine tune the search
the way you want to only show exact
matches for example that's up to you and
of course our website is also responsive
so this grid here on the front page for
example adapts to the screen size
and shows a different amount of items
everything moves around at the correct
time
and even our pagination bar here at the
bottom is responsive so if the screen is
too small there will not be enough place
to show a 10 page numbers for example
instead it changes to a
another kind of view which looks like
this now we have this right button that
we can click
and the current page number and also
this left button and again this changes
with the screen size really cool
the enough but is of course responsive
as well so this moves below
and yeah we will learn how to do this
with Tailwind okay so this is an amazing
project we will be building here and the
focus of one of the main focuses of this
tutorial is next.js server actions
because they haven't really been covered
in any tutorial in detail so far because
they are still an alpha right now and we
will use them extensively throughout
this tutorial in different forms we will
use them from Silver components and from
client components so you will see how
you can cut them and work with them
correctly but there are some
prerequisites for this tutorial because
this is not a complete beginner tutorial
if you have never worked with nexjs
before then you should first watch my
nexjs 13 beginner tutorial here on
YouTube which I will link in the top
right corner of this video in the info
card box because next.js does some magic
under the hood especially when it comes
to a caching pages and you should
understand this when building an xjs
project and I explain all of this in
detail in the linked tutorial alright
then I wish you a lot of fun with this
tutorial and please don't forget to like
this video this is a signal to me that I
should make more videos like this in the
future have fun now it's time to set up
our project and not only will we set up
a next JS project we will also add some
extensions that make it Pleasant to work
with one such extension is prettier
which is a code formatting tool which is
especially useful together with Tailwind
CSS because there's a Tailwind plug-in
that helps you order your classes
properly otherwise working with
tailoring classes can get really messy
really quickly so we will learn how to
set this up properly I will show you how
to set up all of this manually but I
will also put a link in the video
description below to the starting code
that you can download from GitHub the
reason is that of course these different
packages that we use get updates over
time and sometimes these updates break
existing features and to make sure that
you can still watch and follow this
tutorial one year or two years in the
future you can download the starting
code from GitHub where all the packages
and other configuration is already set
up so it's up to you if you want to
create the project manually or download
the starting code just know that if you
watch this tutorial in the future and
you do it manually then you might have
to fix some code throughout this project
all right to create a next.js project
manually we open the folder where we
want to put it and then we have to open
the command line here on Windows we can
do this by holding shift down right
clicking inside this folder and click on
open Powershell window here this might
say open zmd or command line here this
is also fine we just need a command line
window
if you are on Mac or Linux then yeah
open the command line there as well and
navigate to the folder where you want to
initialize the project again you can
skip this whole part if you downloaded
the starting code from GitHub then you
don't have to set up a new project just
clone the repository into the folder
where you want to put it if you worked
with react or next JS before then you
already have node installed but just to
make sure we can check it we can type in
node minus minus version and it should
show a number here and it should also
show a number if you type in npm minus
minus version which is the node package
manager that we use to install packages
then as usual the easiest way to set up
a newer next.js project is to use the
create Next Step command which looks
like this we write npx not npm but npx
and then create minus next minus app and
then add latest and then we run this
we confirmed this year with yes with a
wire and then we have to answer some
questions we have to give our project a
name I'm gonna call this next.js
e-commerce
enter would you like to use typescript
with this project yes we always use
typescript would you like the excellent
eslint helps us find problems in our
code and you always want to use this as
well so again we select yes would you
like to use Tailwind CSS with this
project we select yes here as well which
is really cool because this way we don't
have to configure Tailwind CSS ourselves
it's already set up
would you like to use the srz directory
and this is just for organization I
prefer this so I select yes here as well
use the app router recommended yes this
way we use the new index.js13 app router
instead of the old Pages directory again
if you have never worked with the app
router before you can follow my next.js
beginner tutorial where we use the app
router so we select yes here as well and
this is really important because
otherwise the project structure will be
completely different
so make sure to select yes would you
like to customize the default import
areas no
and then we have answered all questions
we have to wait a few seconds and this
sets up a newer next.js project
okay when this has finished we can close
the command line and now we should see
our new project here next.js e-commerce
we want to open this in vs code so I
right click open encode if you don't
have this option here then you can also
just open the S code manually and drag
and drop the folder in there we'll open
it over the menu you will know how to
open a project I would assume and if you
don't know that the starting project
then open the starting project instead
as usual this gives us a project with a
lot of configuration already set up
and we can open the command line which
you can do overviewer terminal or use
the shortcut next to it
and then we run this project in
development mode with npm run Dev we
type this into the terminal down here
which starts this project on localhost
3000.
so now we can open a browser window
navigate to localhost 3000 and we should
see this default template here but this
is not so interesting for us right now
so we can close this again
and we also stopped the execution of our
npm run Dev by pressing Ctrl Z while our
cursor is in the terminal down here and
then we confirm this with wire because
now we want to install some packages
again this is only necessary if you have
not downloaded the starting code because
in the starting code I already installed
all the packages to make sure that you
have the same version number as me in
the future so you can skip this part if
you don't know that the starting code
from GitHub alright and we need quite a
few packages in this project and we will
install them all at once now at the
beginning
with npmi which is short for install and
then we type in a few different packages
and you have to make sure that you spell
all of them correctly because otherwise
it will not install the correct run ok
so Tailwind CSS is already set up we
should actually zeal
the dependency here in the package.json
file because we selected Taiwan CSS when
we run the create Next Step command so
this is already installed typescript as
well and some other configuration so the
first package we install here is Daisy
UI in our lowercase like this which is a
component library for Tailwind CSS I
will show you how this looks in a moment
the second dependency is Prisma and
between each of these packages we are at
the space the next one is ADD
Prisma slash client
space the next one is next minus of
space
then we have ADD of Slash
Prisma minus adapter
space
prettier
the space and we are almost done
eslint minus config minus prettier
space and one more
prettier minus plug in minus tail wind
CSS so you can pause the video and type
this out by hand if you haven't
downloaded The Styling code
and then we install all of them by
pressing enter
which we take away
and where did I get all these install
commands from well from the
documentation of each of these packages
they will tell you exactly what you have
to install but I prepared all of this
for you already and so you can just
follow my instructions and now all these
dependencies are added here to the
dependencies Block in the package.json
now in case you're wondering why do we
install all of them in the dependencies
and not in Dev dependencies because some
things like eslint or typescript are
only used in development so usually we
install them in depth dependencies so
that we don't upload our project in
production but in xjs this is actually
not necessary you can install everything
in dependencies because the packages
that we don't use in production will
automatically be stripped away when we
build a project so there's no reason to
use the dev dependencies block okay and
then I said that we also want to install
some extensions that make working with
our project more comfortable again all
of the setup is explained in the
documentation of each of these packages
but I prepared all of this for you
already so you just have to follow my
instructions so this is how you normally
set up Tailwind CSS in a project you
have to install some stuff and you have
to add some configuration files but this
is already done for us when we use the
create next app command it already takes
care of all of this for example you can
see these directives here we can
actually look into our project
and they are set up in the globals.css
file up here
but we still have to improve our editor
setup which you can find here under
editor setup in detailing documentation
here they recommend that we install this
intellisense extension which we will do
and also that we set up Tailwind with
predia which is this chord formatting
package that we installed we will do
both of this again most of this is
already done in the starting code on
GitHub but you still have to install the
extensions so you should still follow my
instructions even if you were downloaded
The Styling code so back into our
project we go to the extensions tab
which is this button here
and research for
Tailwind
and then we want this one here the
official Taiwan CSS intellisense plugin
we installed this
and this gives us Auto completion for
Tailwind classes which is very useful
working without this is really really
almost impossible in my opinion so we
need is extension and they also
recommend some configuration down here
which you may do as well so they
recommend this file Association setting
and to change the editor quick
suggestions so let's go into the
settings which we find under file
preferences and then here settings
in the settings search up here we type
in files
Association we don't have to type it out
completely we just want to find this
setting here here we click on add item
entry type in a star
dot CSS and for the value we type in
Taiwan CSS our lowercase like this okay
and this way Tailwind syntax Works in
CSS files so now when we open Global CSS
again this quickly lines up here again
if you remember there was quickly lines
under these lines up here
but not anymore with the setting and we
want to change another setting as well
which is really useful we search for
editor
quick suggestions
and they are off for Strings by default
we want to change this to a on
because this way we get other completion
inside strings and Tailwind CSS classes
are strings and we want Auto completion
for them to pop up automatically so we
change this to on and these steps you
have to do even if you downloaded the
starting code from GitHub because I
can't change your IDE settings for you
you have to do this yourself then we
also need a little bit of configuration
for this UI which is this component
library that we installed earlier we
already did this step up here when we
installed the dependence here but we
have to add something to the Tailwind
config file so we go back into our
project
and open the Tailwind
config.js file and then we go into this
plugins array here and then we want to
enter this part here require there's a
UI
you can type this out by hand
we can also delete this whole theme
block here because this sets this
background image that we don't need
anymore we will set our own background
color later
and then I want to configure the daisy
UI theme
so again this UI is a component Library
so we have different components here
that are already styled like buttons for
example in different colors
model dialogues that we can use are
kinds of stuff so that we don't have to
set up all of this ourselves
progress bars whatever and this comes
with a custom theme but we can configure
this theme appears actually a really
cool theme generator you can find this
under daisyui.com
the docs tell you how you can customize
the theme
and they also have this random generator
which is really cool so this lets you
generate a random theme and you can just
copy paste this into your Tailwind
config file so if you want you can
generate your own theme on this ui.com
you can also keep the default theme I
have prepared a theme which I put in the
Tailwind config file again this is
already added to the starting code I'm
gonna copy paste this in here I will
also add a link to this file under the
video so you can copy paste it from
there again you can skip this step or
you can generate your own theme if you
want but this is the theme I will use it
sets different colors like the primary
color accent color background color and
so on and I also set a background color
in here in this body block this is not
mentioned here in the docs because this
is not part of the default theme but
this way we can change the background
color we could also do this in the
global CSS file the benefit of doing
this here inside the theme is that we
could later create a different theme
like a Dark theme for example with a
different background color instead of
hard coding this into our globals.css
file again you can copy paste this from
the link under the video if you're not
using the starting code okay we save the
changes to this file then we go into the
globals.css file and here we want to
delete everything except for these three
Tailwind lines here at the top they are
necessary for the Tailwind configuration
and the classes that we can use in our
code but we already set up our own
background color so we don't need this
and we also don't need any of these CSS
variables here
so we delete this and save this file
next we want to configure prettier for
Tailwind CSS so we have this automatic
class ordering I was talking about this
is also very useful we already have
prettier installed and we also installed
this prettier plug-interian CSS earlier
when we installed all the packages but
we have to add a little bit of
configuration as mentioned here so back
into our project we want to open our
Explorer here so we click on this icon
and here in the root folder we create a
new file
with this execut name prettier Dot
config.js
and in here we insert this you can pause
the video and type this out by hand or
copy paste it from the GitHub Link in
the description I know setting up all of
these tweets is a bit tedious but it
really makes it easier to work with our
project later prettier also has an
extension that we should install
otherwise we can only execute it over
the terminal but it's much more
convenient to execute this with a
shortcut with a keyboard shortcut so in
the extension search we type in prettier
entry one installed this extension here
click on install
then we want to make this the default
format on so that when we click the
formatting shortcut on our keyboard it
uses pretty on instead of another
formatter so again we open the settings
over file preferences settings
and research for default formatter
and we want to change this from none to
prettier which should be somewhere
in this list you probably already
thought yeah right here
so now we can use the formatting
shortcut which is alt shift F on Windows
by default to use prettier to format our
files and I just did this and as you can
see I changed the intendation because
prettier is very opinionated formatter
they don't give us a lot of
customization options instead they have
a lot of rules that will automatically
be applied when we use prettier to
format the file like using two spaces
for intendation for example pretty or is
very useful because it also
automatically adds semicolons in the
correct places it adds line breaks when
necessary it's really much better than
the default formatter and we are almost
done with our configuration but we still
have to set up prettier to work properly
together with eslant otherwise they can
conflict again this is described in the
next JS documentation we already
installed eslint config prettier earlier
now we have to go into this eslint RZ
Json file and make a little change down
so we search for
Json what we do is we turn this value
here into an array by surrounding this
with scrap brackets entry at the second
string in here
which just stays prettier
we saved us and this little change makes
sure that eslint and prettier don't
conflict with each other there are two
more extensions that I want to install
that are very useful
for one eslint has an extension I
already installed this one I recommend
that you install this as well because
this way we see our eslint warnings
directly in our code editor and we don't
have to execute a terminal command all
the time and one more
Prisma which is the orm that we will use
with our mongodb database also has an
extension
this one is also incredibly useful
because later when we set up our schema
file we get syntax highlighting there we
get Auto completion and this also helps
us format this file properly so I
recommend that you install this as well
that's it for all the configuration and
extensions we have to set up I just want
to install one more package that I
forgot earlier so again we open the
terminal and type in npmi sort Cod again
I will put this one in the starting code
as well this is just another package
that we will need later so make sure to
install this and it should be added to
the package.json down here okay we can
close all of these tabs here all the
packages and extensions are installed
and configured I also set up a few
images for this project again I added
them to the starting code but if you set
up the project manually I will also link
these images in the description under
the video so you can download them from
there I added these images to this
project for one I replaced the fluff
icon here I use this logo instead of the
default fav icon I also downloaded this
open graph minus image into the app
folder this is the social media preview
image which will be shown when via copy
paste a link to our website on social
media on Twitter or Facebook for example
this file needs this exact name and it
has to be added right in the app folder
again you can download it and put it in
there if you're not using the starting
code and two more images that we will
use throughout this project are inside
this assets folder so you can create a
new folder inside the app folder here
colored assets
and put these two images in there for
one it's the logo we will use for this
website and then this profile pic
placeholder in the case a user is logged
in but they don't have a profile picture
okay again I will take the project as it
is right now I will push it to GitHub I
will call this Branch starting code or
starting point and I will link it under
the video description so you can
download this whole thing without having
to set it up manually but it's still
useful to know how to set up all of this
yourself manually alright and in the
next section we will set up our mongodb
database and then we can start coding
all right next we want to set up our
mongodb database and the easiest way to
do this is to use mongodb Atlas which is
a cloud hosting service for mongodb and
they also have a free tier available
that we can use to build our project so
you can search for mongodb Atlas on
Google and then just click on the link
you'll find here we have to create an
account and log in you can click here
and start create the website probably
looks a bit different in the future just
create a free account log into this
account I already have an account and
here I want to set up a new project I
already have a project but that's from
my next JS course I create a new project
here
again the UI might look a bit different
on your side just find a button that
says create a new project
then we give this project a name again
I'm gonna call this next.js e-commerce
you can give this any name you want
we click on next yeah this is already
set our automatically then we click on
create project and we have to wait a
moment
and then we want to create a database in
this new project
here we can select m0 which is the free
tier but this is more than enough to
build a little practice project you can
even use this for a small production
websites by the way we can select where
our database is stored and in what
region we can keep the default settings
here you can change the name of this
cluster but you can also keep it as
cluster zero we don't have to change
anything else and we click on Create and
now we have to select mountains or Hills
okay this is a hill this is a here I
don't know if this right here is a here
let's see here we are we are a human
then we have to set up a username and a
password to later log into our database
I want to set the username to a Florian
I keep the passport here and we click on
create user
then we have to add the IP address from
where we want to connect to this
database in development we are
connecting from our local machine from
our computer right so we have to add our
current IP address with this button but
this is already done down here
and we have set up a user and everything
then we can click on finish and close
and then on go to a databases and now we
have a hosted mongodb database I like
mongodb Atlas because they take care of
a lot of stuff for you and that you
otherwise have to configure yourself
like for example replica sets which as
far as I know are additional observers
that contain the exact same data as your
database just in different locations in
case one of them goes down at least this
is how I understand it but this is
already set up in mongodb Atlas by
default okay and now what I want to do
is I want to go to our collections which
we can do over this button
you can also click on data services here
and of course we don't have any data in
our database yet but I want to add some
data manually I want to add some
products here to work with and later we
will add the page to our website where
we can add products over a form but for
now we add them manually
we have to give the database a name
I'm going to call it e-commerce we want
to create a collection called products
and we don't want to change any of these
additional preferences we click on
create
and now we have this products collection
here and here we want to add one product
which we can do over in the document
okay and for now we will just use some
dummy data but the names of the fields
are important because we will create our
Prisma schema from the documentary
Creator so we have to decide what fields
we want to have in a product document we
want each product to have a name right
just gonna call this product name again
this is just dummy data for now
then we add another field this one will
be the description
product description
each product we have in image URL
which I spell in camera case like this
and for now I just write hdps colon
slash slash
um
product minus image Dot come whatever
this is the URL and this is just a
placeholder for now doesn't matter
then we add the field for the price
and all of these fields are strings by
default but we want to change the price
to Aint 32 so this is a number
and again we put the placeholder in here
999 doesn't matter but we store the
price as an integer not as a float even
though a price can have decimals for
cents but you can't store prices as
floats because floats are not exact if
you want to know why floats are not
exact you can Google this but you should
store prices in zense this way we always
have the exact number so this is why we
don't select double or decimal here but
the normal int okay and we insert this
dummy product into our database and now
it's here in our products collection and
as I already mentioned we use Prisma to
work with our mongodb database this is a
library that we can use in next.js or
also in node.js and this just makes it
easier to work with our database because
it gives us a nice client on which we
call these different functions for the
different database operations it gives
us types and everything and Prisma is a
very popular one especially for next Js
again the installation and set up for
Prisma is described in the Prisma
documentation but I will show you each
step in this video so we go back into
our project and we already installed the
package for Prisma now we open the
command line again
entry execute npx again not npn but npx
Prisma in it spell it out exactly like
this we execute this
and this does two things for one it
created this dot end file with the
database URL here inside it but this is
not the correct connection string as you
can see this is just a placeholder we
get the correct connection string out of
our Atlas backend here somewhere here is
a button that says connect I think we
see it when we click on data services
here's the connect button
and here on drivers we can find this
connection string we can ignore these
other instructions because we don't use
the native mongodb driver we use Prisma
to work with our database but we need
this part here so we copy this
into our project
entry replace this part here in the
string
then we also have to replace this part
here with the angle brackets for the
actual password so we paste this in here
and we also have to insert the database
name here after the slash this is the
name we gave our mongodb database so
let's see here
I think I call this just e-commerce
right
you can see this in the collections here
this is the name we care about
we enter this same name here after the
slash otherwise this creates a newer
database but we want to use the database
that we already set up then we can
delete these commands up here they are a
bit confusing and unnecessary
and then we also want to add this dot
end file to the git ignore so that we
don't push our database credentials to
GitHub so we open the dot get ignore
can scroll all the way to the bottom and
add dot end here and now this is grayed
out which indicates that this file is
not pushed to GitHub now normally in the
next JS project you put your credentials
into this dot NF dot local files and
project configuration goes into the dot
end file the problem is Prisma by
default doesn't look into this
inf.logger file it looks into the normal
end file so the easiest way to handle
this is to just put our credentials
directly into dot nth this is the same
what we also do in a normal node.js
project because otherwise we have to add
additional packages and configuration to
make Prisma look into this dot local
file but I don't want to do this here
and it's also not necessary because
putting credentials into the normal.n
file is totally fine you just have to
make sure that you put it into the git
ignore file so you don't push it to
GitHub okay and the second thing that
the press my Inlet command that we
executed earlier did is it created this
Prisma folder here with this
schema.prisma file inside it here we
want to change the provider inside data
source DB not appear in the client but
down here from broadcast SQL to a
mongodb because we are using a mongodb
database and you can also use Prisma
with SQL databases and this is the part
here that makes Prisma look in the end
file for this database URL here that
contains the connection string so the
spelling of this variable has to be the
same as whatever is entered in here and
as you can see we also have syntax
highlighting in here just like a normal
typescript code for example but this
only works because we installed the
Prisma extension earlier
this gives a syntax highlighting Auto
completion formatting and so on
otherwise the escort would handle this
like a plain text file okay and here's a
very cool thing we can do we already
added the damier product to our database
right and we added the name of the
database to the connection string
Ecommerce
now we can tell Prisma to pull the data
that we added to our collection and
generate a schema from this data so we
don't have to set us up ourselves so
remember we have a name description
image URL which are all strings and this
price which is a number
now in the command line we can type
npx
Prisma
this is the exact command we execute
this
this shows an error because I haven't
saved the changes to the schema.press
modifier yet so we save this file and
execute this again now it should work
it opens this window here because we
have to allow this to execute on windows
so yeah just click on allow access and
you won't have to do this again in the
future here it says introspected one
model and wrote it to a schema.prisma
and as you can see now we have our
products model here with the name
description image URL and price the
correct types and the idea is set up as
a mongodb object idea this is called
introspection this way you can invert
the Prisma schema from the data you
already have in the database but you can
also do it the other way around you can
also make changes to the schema and push
these changes to a mongodb and we
actually want to do this now because I
want to add some more stuff in here that
we can't really generate through
introspection we want to add this
created add
timestamp which will be of type date
time and again we get Auto completion
because we installed the Prisma
extension
and then afterwards you write dot add
default
and in here we pass now
which is a function
this means when we create a new product
it will automatically set the created
timestamp to the correct time
and then we also add an updated ad
timestamp which again is date time
until we add this updated ads annotation
which takes care that this timestamp is
automatically updated when we modify a
product and now we have the formatting
keyboard shortcut which on Windows is
shift alt F we can format this file but
they want us to configure a default
formatter let's see here yeah here we
select Prisma which is the Prisma
extension
and now it formats this file properly I
don't know what the keyboard shortcut to
format is on Linux and Mac but you can
Google this if you don't know it there's
one more thing I want to do on so our
collection is called products right this
is the same name our collection SEO and
you usually call this the plural of the
word because this contains multiple
products but when we work with our data
in our app we want the operations to be
called on dot product and not DOT
products for example I want to call
product.create or product.find and not
products.create because the program is a
bit misleading and I also want the model
name to be capitalized so we change the
model name to a product singular but now
we have to tear Prisma to what
collection this is connected right
because this collection is called
products the name is different we can do
this by going down here below the last
field and then we write two ads map and
here we can add the name of the
collection lowercase products and plural
now this model is connected to this
collection and this way the model and
the collection can have different names
and now instead of pulling the changes
from the database into the schema we
want to push the changes from the schema
into the database
so instead of DB pull we execute npx
Prisma DB push
so that these changes will be applied to
our mongodb database
let's execute this
okay it says that the database is
already in sync so it seems like the
changes we made in our schema doesn't
require any changes in Atlas but it also
doesn't hurt to execute this throughout
this tutorial we will make some more
changes to our schema here so this is
not the last time we have modified this
and we want to execute one more command
npx
Prisma generate make sure to spell it
correctly and then we run this
this generates the Prisma client which
you can use to call our different
database operations on and whenever you
make changes to your schema like we
changed the name of the model here then
you have to regenerate as Prisma client
so that you can use this new model in
your code and you get Auto completion
and everything but again we will do this
a few more times throughout this
tutorial so you will understand when you
have to do this next we need to
initialize this Prisma client like it is
shown down here by calling the press my
client Constructor and we want to make
this prismaclient reusable throughout
our app so we put this into a separate
file
for this we go into the srz folder here
where all our project source code is in
in here we create a new folder called
lib lib is just a naming convention for
a folder where people usually put like
utility functions for example or
functions that use other packages like
Prisma in our case but it's up to you
what folder structure you follow
in lib I want to put another folder
called DB just for organization DB
obviously stands for database and in
here we put a file which we call
prisma.ts this is a typescript file
to use Prisma in development mode and
xjs we need a little bit of
special configuration which is described
in the Prisma documentation because when
we save a project the app is restarted
right and we don't want to set up a new
Prisma client every time this happens
so we use the code that is described
down here this sets up a new Prisma
client and adds it to This Global this
object which is just a way to make this
client globally available as a Singleton
throughout our app and only if the
Prisma client doesn't exist on This
Global this object then we instantiate a
new one and this is only executed in
development in production this is not
necessary so back into our project I
paste the code we just saw you can pause
the video and type this out by hand or
again copy it from the GitHub repository
and then I press the shortcut again to
format this file you don't have to do
this but the cool thing is that since we
have pretty uninstalled it automatically
adds semicolons for example and it also
replace the Zinger chords for double
quotes because again prettier is an
opinionated chord format so they make
some decisions for you like not using
single chords for example but again if
you use this or not it's up to you I
recommend that you use it and now we are
ready to use Prisma in our project and
our database is already set up so now
the fun part can begin now we write
actual code just one more thing I want
to delete our dummy product here we only
needed this for introspection but we
will later add actual products through
our app so let's delete this document
and in the next section we will add our
first page to our website a page where
we can add a newer product and for this
we will use next.js server actions so
this will be really interesting
okay so back in our project we open the
terminal again and we want to start this
project in development mode with npm run
Dev
then we open localhost 3000 to see our
website and I put this in split screen
so that we can make changes to our
website and see these changes live I
want to add a new page to our website
over which we can add a newer product
because without products we don't have
anything to display right so we open the
right bar here and then in the app
folder we create a new folder called add
minus product
and in here we put a fire page dot TSX
this way we can create a page under
localhost 3000 slash add minus product
if you don't know how routing works in
the next js13 app router then I highly
recommend that you watch my Nexus 13
beginner tutorial first because there I
explain all of this why we have to
create a page.tsx file how we can create
nested sub-roads and so on in this
tutorial here I will assume that you
already know this stuff okay and in here
we can write the code for this component
for this page
so we export a default function
entry carlet at product page
as usual the name of this component does
not matter the only thing that matters
is that we export it from a page.tsx
file and from this component we want to
return some UI right so let's put a div
in here
and let's put in H1 in here a headline
that says
add product let's save this and now we
should be able to navigate to a
localhost 3000
slash add product which is the name we
gave this folder where we put this page
file in
and there's our headline and now we can
style this headline using class names
and if you haven't used or heard of
Tailwind CSS before the way this works
is that we don't set up CSS files
instead we write our CSS directly in
here by using different utility classes
that each fulfill a single purpose for
example we want to make this text a bit
bigger so we can type in and now we get
Auto completion because remember we
earlier set up Auto completion inside
strings in the settings and together
with the tailband we escort extension we
get this Auto completion here which is
really useful
for example we have text LG and here you
can see what this actually does which
CSS attributes this actually changes
this sets the font size to this 1.125
Ram
so when we add this and save our changes
the font gets a bit bigger you can also
hover over one of these Tailwind classes
to see the CSS that this applies it
changes the font size and the line
height as well again this only works if
you have the Tailwind extension
installed where do I get these classes
from well either you can just see what
other completion suggests to you and
sometimes this is enough but often you
just have to look in the Tailwind
documentation
so they describe all these different
classes that you can use at first this
can seem overwhelming but you actually
get used to this very fast and you don't
have to read all of this you can just
Google for Tailwind box Shadow for
example or you can search in the quick
search here and then you will find the
necessary classes you have to use to
apply a box Shadow for example
so let's add some more we want to make
the text bigger we want to add the
margin bottom for which we have this MB
minus classes
we use MB minus three
this adds a bit of margin to the next
element below but we can't see it yet we
also want to make the text bold which we
can do with font minus bold
and since we set up the prettier
extension for Tailwind earlier we can
now reformat this code with our
formatting shortcut again on Windows
this is shift IDF and it will
automatically reorder these classes here
to the appropriate order as you can see
it put the margin button to the front
Tailwind has a special convention for
the order of these classes I don't know
what the rules exactly they follow but
the prettier extension makes sure that
the same order is applied everywhere
which really makes it easier to keep an
overview over these Clauses then below
the H1 I want to put a form
and in this form we will later enter the
product information to create a new
product in our database so this is a
normal HTML form tag and in here we put
an input
which we can give a self-closing tag
with a slash and a closing angle bracket
and we want to add some props to this
input
when we save this I think we should
already see something here we have this
very not good looking unstyled input
here we can style this again with
K1 classes by adding the class name prop
so I want to add some Merchant bottom to
this input and I want to set the width
to 100 for which we have this W of foil
table class when we save this the input
field gets the margin and the full width
now one downside of raw Tailwind is that
you start with completely unstyled
elements right and you have to Define
all this yes as yourself this can be a
bit overwhelming because you often have
to add a lot of classes to create a UI
that looks good this is why we also use
Daisy UI in this project this UI
basically adds more convenience classes
that we can use to style different
components for example somewhere here is
a text input
this is what we want to add to our
project and this one here looks better
than the one we have right now right
and let's say we want to use text input
with border here we can see the jsx we
already have an input and here are the
class names and this input and input
border classes are coming from this UI
they simply combine multiple Tailwind
classes into a single one so that we
don't have to install all of this from
zero so let's try this out
input and input boiler let's add them
here import let's hover over this and as
you can see it contains quite a lot of
CSS
and we want input bordered when we save
this our input now looks much better
of course we still need some padding
here so that's the input field doesn't
go all the way to the edges of the
screen but we will take care of this in
a moment and again we can use the
formatting shortcuts to reorder these
classes properly so input border moves
to the front followed by the remaining
classes
okay but we still want to add some more
props to the input field here
for one we want to make it required so
that we have to type something in before
we can send this form this is taken care
of by the browser we have to set a name
this way we can get the value out of
this input field later and the name will
also be named because this field will
contain the product name
let's also set the placeholder let's set
it to name as well and when we save this
we get this placeholder here we can type
something in and later we will get the
product name out of this input field
again I use the formatting shortcut to
format this properly and it also puts
the closing tag into a new line I really
like prettier for this reason it also
does stuff like adding parentheses
automatically so if we remove these
parentheses here from the return
statement and put it like this instead
and use the formatting shortcut again it
adds these parentheses automatically and
I really like this because it helps you
keep your formatting consistent
throughout the whole project okay and
below our first input field we put
another input field for the product
description but since the description is
usually longer we don't use an input
field we use a text area
which is basically a big input field
where we can put in larger amounts of
text over multiple lines
we make this required as well
reset the name to description
and the placeholder as well
just with an uppercase deal
which by default looks like this we can
change the size of this which is really
cool
but of course the one is stylus using
Daisy UI and Tailwind classes
Daisy UI gives us text area and text
area border
and then again mb3
and W foil
and now it looks like this with rounded
corners
and some highlighting
then we need two more input Fields below
for the image URL and the price so let's
copy the input field that we already
have
paste it two times because the styling
will be the same
we change the name of the third one to
image URL like this
we change the placeholder to image URL
as well in readable form
and then we can set the type of this
input field to URL this way the browser
checks that we actually put something in
here that looks like a URL with https
and so on otherwise the browser will not
accept our input which is really useful
and this down here is of course the
price
we set a placeholder to price as well
entries that the type to number because
this way we can only type numbers in
here and no other characters now one
thing that happens when you use Tailwind
is that you often have repetition
between classes for example all our
input Fields here have the same margin
bottom and width class applied to them
right now you might be inclined to try
to get rid of this by creating
abstractions like separate components
that already include these classes but
this is actually not necessary and you
shouldn't do this too earlier
the Taiwan documentation actually talks
about this and one thing they recommend
is to just use multi-cursor editing for
example if we want to change the margin
of all our input Fields here we can just
click on the first one and then in vs
chord we can press Ctrl D or command D
on Mac to select
the next occurrence of this word now we
have all four Merchant bottom three
selected and we can change all of them
at once to a different value if you want
so this is how you can work efficiently
with Tailwind classes even if you have
to repeat yourself below the last input
field but still inside the form
we add a button
which was there at product
then we go into the opening tag of the
button and we set the type to submit and
when we have a button with type submit
inside the form it will automatically
submit this form when we click this
button this is just default HTML
behavior and this down here is our
Button as you can see entailment by
default nothing has any style applied to
it so right now it just looks like
normal text so let's add some class
names
to style this button
we use the daisy button class BTN
which Styles this like a gray button we
can add some color with BTM primary and
I also want this button to take up the
full width
so we also set this to BTN block
which I think just sets a width here of
100.
and now it looks much better
is our form is ready but again we need
some padding on the edges of the screen
it looks a bit weird right now but
instead of doing this inside this page I
want to do it in the layout TSX file
remember from my next JS beginner
tutorial that this is the root layout
it's located directly inside the app
folder and this wraps all pages
throughout our whole website to be more
exact our pages are inside this children
component here and this is rendered
inside this HTML body and in this layout
we can add styling that we want to have
applied throughout our whole website for
example by default this Intel font from
Google fonts is applied to the whole
body be at this class name here and this
body wraps all pages right now I wanna
wrap children into another attack the
HTML main tag
because each page contains the main
content of the page and we will later
put enough bar Above This main tag and
the footer below for now I want to apply
some styling to this main tag again this
styling will wrap all pages for example
I want to add some padding which we can
do with this P minus 4 class now it
already looks much better I also want to
have some Max and Min width applied to
all pages because as you can see this
takes up the full width of the screen no
matter how big the screen is I want to
constrain this for this again we have
different Tailwind classes available
next minus W lets us set a Max width and
I want to use the largest one here which
is 7xl and we can see how big this is
when I zoom out a bit because when I
record my videos I always increase the
size on the screen of everything so it's
easier to read this is to realize this
page and form have and this is also the
size it should have on your side so now
our Pages don't get bigger than this
anymore so this is a 1920 pixel Monitor
and Max
w7xl is 2080 pixels but of course you
can play around with this and use
another value if you want but of course
I want to have this part here Zen dot on
the screen right we can do this with
margin order
which we set with M minus Auto now it is
ascended on the screen and I also want
to set a Min width which we can do with
Min minus W1 but here we don't have as
many different options available there
aren't any classes by default for
different screen sizes like we have for
Max width but we can actually set an
arbitrary size and this also works with
Max width this also works with other
attributes when you want to do this in
Tailwind CSS we can add the value in
square brackets like this after another
minus
and in here we can write 300 PX for
example for 300 pixels now we set the
main width to this arbitrary value of
300 pixels and now when I make the
screen very small
the page itself never gets smaller than
300 pixels because we don't want to
scratch it too much but again you can
play around with these values and use
other values if you want as usual we can
press our formatting shortcuts to have
pretty uh realign everything properly
and then I also want to change the meta
data here in this metadata object we
change the title from this default
create next app to a flomazon I explain
metadata in my nextjs 13 beginner
tutorial this will now be the title of
the page when we save this we can see a
flowmason appear in the tab and this
will also show up for example when we
paste a link to our website on social
media let's also change the description
and I set this to our tagline which is
we make your wallet cry because we are
in e-commerce app
so this way we change the metadata
throughout our whole website so all
pages now have this flomas on as the
title and this description which shows
up on social media but we can also
modify the metadata for specific Pages
like for our ads product page for
example we go all the way to the top
above our component
and we export this const metadata here
as well
you have to make sure that the spelling
is correct are lowercase otherwise
next.js will not recognize this and here
we just want to overwrite the title
to the name of the page
add product minus and then again the
flomas on and when we save this we
change the title but only for this page
on all other Pages we still have the
default flowmas on title and as a
reminder as long as we don't use the use
client directive at the top of the file
this whole component is rendered on the
server if we were fetching any data in
this component then this data would also
be fetched server side and the client
would only receive the finished page
with the data inside it but here we
don't fetch any data it's just static
HTML and now when we submit this form we
want to store a new product in our
database right one way to handle this
would be to turn this into a client
component so that we can interact with
this form client-side and execute
JavaScript we could take the input of
this form and send it via a fetch
request to our own server endpoint which
then adds the product to the database
this is the usual flow why do we need a
server endpoint where we can't make
database operation on the client why
because this requires us to connect to
our database so we need our database
credentials and we can't expose our
database credentials on the client
otherwise the user would be able to do
anything they want with our database
this is where we have to Route requests
like this over our own server so the
server actually has the connection to
the database and the user can just
request to add this object but they
can't mess around with our database so
again normally we would set up an API
endpoint here in our next JS project
which we can do with route handlers
alternatively you could also set up a
separate server like an Express server
for example that runs on a completely
different project then we would turn our
page into a client component so that we
can execute JavaScript which is
necessary to make a fetch request to our
server we would send the product data
there and the server would then insert
this data into the database but as you
already see there are a lot of steps
involved and next.js recently introduced
other actions which are still in Alpha
right now and in a nutshell they are
basically a way to do a server mutations
directly in our components without
having to set up an end point so this is
just more concise because we basically
just put a function into our component
and we can call this function it's very
intuitive and it's less work than
setting up a separate endpoint so let's
go back into our project and see how
this works we can declare such a server
function directly in a server component
if we had the US client directive at the
top of the file we could not put it in
here but since we don't have any
client-side features in this component
we can put our server action directly
into this file it will be an async
function because we make a database
operation
and let's call it add product
we can call the server action from a
server component via this form here
by adding the action attribute this way
we still don't need any JavaScript this
fully Works in a server component
and here we simply pass our ads product
function
now when we call this function we get
sent the data as form data so we create
a parameter form data and it will be of
type form data
then at the top of this function we add
this string that says
use server this is very similar to the
use client directive that we have to put
in a client component this states
next.js that this is a server action
otherwise this will just not work
and in here we can do a database
operation so we can cut a weight then we
use Prisma which we import from our
libdb folder
that we set up earlier
then when we click dot with the product
here where is this coming from this is
coming from our schema because we call
the model product and this is connected
to the products collection in our
database if you don't see product then
make sure that you executed this npx
Prisma generate command that we run
earlier because this generates this
Prisma client
and whenever you make changes to your
personal schema you have to recreate the
client with the new functions available
I want to start this again with npm run
Dev and on here we can call functions
like
create for example to create a new
document
and we add the data of this document as
an argument Within calibrases
now in the server function we are
allowed to call prisma.create which
again does a database operation if you
try to call Prisma create in a client
component for example when we click a
button then this will not work because
again database operations can only be
done on the server even if you try this
you will get an error message because
Prisma protects you from accidentally
exposing your database credentials on
their client so it will throw an error
if you try to do this but inside a
server action we can do this because
this will only be executed on the server
this code here never gets to the client
so again this is the same as if we would
have set up an API route in next.js or a
server endpoint in Express for example
this is a little server endpoint to make
pulse requests on and inside create we
can pass data another pair of curly
braces and in here we put the actual
data of the product we want to create so
the name the price description and so on
but of course we first have to get the
data out of this from data object here
so let's go above we can get our values
out of the form data by their name we
gave this input fields it looks like
this we create a cons name
equals from data dot get
and here we pass the name of this field
which in this case is name
and this value is now of type form data
entry value
we can get the actual input
by calling to a string on it now the
input can be empty so this adds the save
call Operator so name is string or
undefined later we will also learn how
we can call these server actions from
client components this is actually
possible and then we get the data not
passed as form data but as normal
arguments you will see all of this later
when we call a server action from a
server component then we basically have
to do it over a form action because this
doesn't require any JavaScript and this
passes us the data in form of form data
okay let's get the other values out of
here as well
cons description equals form data.get
description and again recall to a string
then we do this for the image URL
and for a price but the price is a
number so we wrap this into this number
Constructor which passes the number
string into an actual number
so in here again we pass form data get
the name of this field is price
we don't have to cut to a string because
number can actually handle this value
but again from data get can return
undefined in which case the number will
throw an error so we add a fallback
value here with two vertical bars and
then we add the zero so this will be the
fallback value in case the price input
is empty just so that we don't get an
error but since we made all these fields
here required with this required prop I
also want to check in This Server action
that we actually got these values
otherwise we will throw an error because
we don't expect any of these inputs to
be empty so let's check if exclamation
mark name
or exclamation mark description
or the image URL is missing or the price
is missing
then this is invalid input so we will
throw an error
which was a missing required Fields or
whatever you want us to say
so now since we checked that these
values are defined down here they are
guaranteed to be defined
so now we can pass the name the
description the image URL and the price
to Prisma and this will create a new
product document with this data and
after we added the product I want to
redirect to the front page
so we call this redirect function but
this import here is wrong when we select
this it adds the import like this but we
want to import this from next slash
navigation this is the correct one
and then we want to redirect to the
front page which we can do like this
so now we have some very simple
validation here if I try to send this
without typing anything in then the
browser shows us a message here
and it should even detect when this is
not a valid URL
those are the native browser validation
methods that we are using down here with
required and the type prop if you want
to use something like react hook form
here for validation then this is also
possible but for this you have to make
this a client component because this
requires JavaScript but I want to keep
this page a server component to show you
how you can use server actions from
server components later we will also
learn how to cut server actions from
client components and then you can do
everything that requires JavaScript but
again in the server component you use
this form action here and this simply
sends the form data to the server action
and later we will also protect this
route so that we can only add a new
product if we are logged in but we
haven't implemented authentication yet
we will do this later now one more thing
we have to change before we can try this
out since server actions are still in
Alpha we have to enable them explicitly
which we do in the next config file here
we go into this next config block we add
this experimental block
colon curly braces and then here we have
this server actions field
which we set to true this way we can use
server actions in this project
one more thing we will have images in
our app that we will load from
unsplash.com this is just a nice website
where you can find free images and we'll
use this for our product images if you
watch my next JS beginner tutorial then
you know that we have to allow the URLs
where we want to load images from and we
do this also inside the next config you
can put it above or below experimental
doesn't matter I'm gonna put it above we
have this images field again colon curly
braces we add a comma here
and in here we have this remote patterns
value to which we pass an array
repairs an array of JavaScript objects
so square brackets curly braces
and in here we can define a hostname you
can add multiple of these if you want to
load images from multiple sources and
the Base address where we load these
images from we add this as a string as
images Dot
unsplash.com if we don't do this then we
will get an error later when we try to
load these images
so we'll save this and then we have to
restart our Dev server it stopped
automatically if it didn't press Ctrl Z
confirm with wire
and execute NP and run Dev again
otherwise the changes of next config
will not be applied
okay now let's add some products and to
show you that this works with our
JavaScript let's actually disable
JavaScript you don't have to do this I
just want to show this to you so in the
Chrome Dev tools I can press Ctrl shift
p
can search for disabled JavaScript and
just to make sure that this is applied I
refresh the page but we have to keep the
Chrome Dev tools open when we close the
JavaScript will be enabled again again
you can get product images from unsplash
just go to unsplash.com and search for I
don't know product images
and use any of these here just open them
right click copy image address
and then you can use this here as the
image URL for the name description and
price you can write anything you want I
have already prepared some data
so this is the title just gonna copy
paste this here a description and by the
way I use chat gbt to come up with
funnier product titles and product
descriptions so I didn't come up with
this myself
so the image here is coming from
unsplash again you can copy the image
URL from there and I set the price for
example to 999 which is 9.99
remember that JavaScript is still
disabled but when we click add product
all of this should work
we don't see a loading indicator yet we
will add this later but we get
redirected to the front page so it seems
that this worked let's check our
database
so in Atlas
in our products collection we should now
see one entry with this data we inserted
and it automatically generates the
created ad and updated ad timestamps so
this worked and we executed this over
our server action here without having to
set up a separate server endpoint and
without any JavaScript but when we added
the product we didn't have a loading
indicator right which is not great
because we usually want to see that some
request is running right now we also
want to disable the button so that we
can't click it twice now we can't put a
loading State into our server component
here because the loading State requires
JavaScript and state and those are
client component features but in a
client component we can't put a server
action at least not directly in there
like we did here but what we can do is
we can make only the loading indicator a
client component and we can use a
special hook to hook into the loading
state of this form here even if the form
itself is in a server component this is
a new hook their introduce just recently
it's also still experimental but I want
to show you how this works so you know
all these different apis that we have
available
so I want to put the loading indicator
directly into this button so we extract
this button into a separate component
and make it the client component so that
we can put the loading state in there to
make this button reusable let's put it
into a separate components folder not
into our app folder here so I right
click on sr0
entry Creator components folder
in here we put a new file
which we call
from submit button.tsx
but of course the name is up to you
this will be a client component so we
add the use client directive at the top
again I explained this in my next JS
beginner tutorial
then we want to export a component
function from here
form submit button
we want to add some props to this form
submit button
so we create a type that we call form
submit button props
equal sign curly braces now if you
watched my other next.js and react to
turrets then you know that I usually
make these props in interface and not
the type because it's generally
recommended to use interfaces until you
need a type but here we do need a type
wire because I want to extend this type
and you can't do this with interfaces I
want to go down here after the closing
curly brace
right ampersand
component props which is then import
from react
like this
and then we add a type to component
props which we do with angle brackets
and then here we press button as a
string
component props is a really cool
convenience type that we can use and
react this way our form submit button
will not only accept the props that we
put into the form submit button props
but also all the props a normal button
accepts for example you can disable a
normal HTML button with the disabled
prop right and instead of putting this
value in here directly we can just say
okay we want to accept all the same
props in normal button expects and this
is what component props does again this
only works with type and not with
interface this is why I made the props a
type this time okay but we still want to
add two or more values right in our form
submit button props
the first one is the children prop of
type react dot react node
in case you don't know what the children
prop is this allows us to pass a
component between the opening and the
closing tag of another component so in
the normal button
we enter the text inside the opening and
the closing tag right like add product
for example and we can do the same with
our form submit button via this children
prop so whatever we pass in here between
the opening and the closing tag of our
form submit button will be passed via
this children prop this means that the
name of this prop has to be spelled like
this if you change this then this will
not be recognized as the children prop
anymore and we also want to be able to
pass some styling to this button from
the outside
so we pass a class name but we make this
optional with a question mark so we
don't have to pass one
and this will be of type string this way
whenever we call this from submit button
component and use it somewhere we can
pass classes from the outside if we want
but we don't have to
okay and then we add these props here
inside the parentheses of our form
submit button
so we wanted to structure them with
curly braces as usual
colon we set the type to form the mid
button props and now between the curly
braces we have children
and class name
and then we want to return some UI in
this block down here right let's keep it
simple for now just to see that this
works
we just add a normal button here
between the opening and the closing tag
we add the children because we want to
render the children that we pass to the
form submit Button as the children of
the button we render in here
let's save this and see if this works
we go back to our page
entry replace
this button here for our
form submit button
save this again so it seems to work
because we still have a button that says
add product but it's unstyled again
because we haven't added any styling to
this button in here yet so let's finish
this let's go in the opening tag of the
button and add a class name here but we
remove the quotation marks and put curly
braces here instead because this way we
can put a back text string in here a
back tech string allows us to use normal
string classes like BTN and BTM primary
but we can also put our class name in
here additionally
because in the backtake string we can
put a variable with a dollar sign and
curly braces this way both the button
classes but also our optional class name
String are applied to this button
let's try this out as well let's save
this and you can immediately see that
the styling changes
but this also means that we don't need
the BTN and the BTM primary class
on our page anymore because they are
hard-coded on this from a bit button but
we don't want to hard code the button
block value because I want to keep this
optional so we pass this from the
outside as the class name prop instead
okay cool then I also want to set the
type of this button to submit which of
course again means
we don't need this prop here anymore
okay so now our button works the same as
before with the same styling and now we
want to get the loading state in here
and as I already said there is an
experimental new hook that we can use
to get the loading state of this form
here where the storm submit button is
placed in even if the form itself is in
a server component it's enough if the
submit button is a client component so
we have to add another import
curly braces from reacts done so this is
not coming from next.js this is actually
coming from react 18 and in here we
should find experimental U.S form status
but afterwards we also add s and we
rename this so that we don't have to use
this awkward long name here in our code
we rename this to just use form status
then we can use this hook in our
component
so again we destructure a const and we
call this use form status this
automatically hooks into the parent form
of this button
and in here we have different values we
care about pending which is the loading
state
so when we submit our form until our
server action here has returned its
pending will be set to true and we can
show a loading indicator
I also want to disable the button while
this is loading so we set disabled
to a pending and I also want to show a
loading spinner here right next to the
text inside this button
and for this again we have Daisy UI
classes that we can use somewhere here
should be a
a loading indicator
and they are different ones available
you can choose whatever you like I want
to use this one here so back in our code
I put this
inside the button tag so between the
opening and the closing tag
above the children
we add an expression in curly braces
if pending is true so pending to Amazon
science then we want to render this band
with this loading indicator so this is a
span with a safe closing tag
which gets the class names loading
and loading
spinner
we let prettier we format this properly
so this loading spinner will be shown
while pending is true and pending is
coming from the form status one more
thing we have to do we accept these
component props from the button right
but right now we don't apply them to our
button here in order to do this we go
right here where we are destructure our
props and we write dot dot dot props
this way catch all the remaining props
that we pass to our form submit button
which don't have explicit names so all
the props that we pass
for the button component props basically
this is this syntax we have to use for
this and we also want to apply them to
our button here right so we go in the
button tag again and we do this all the
way at the top as the first prop this
way the other props that we pass below
will overwrite these props because we
usually want these ones to have priority
over whatever button props we pass so we
pass the rest props as the very first
argument
curly braces again we write dot dot dot
props now all these props that we pass
here will be applied to our button tag
okay let's save everything and then try
this out again so now in this page we
are using our form submit button it
should still work the same but it should
have a loading indicator and it should
also be disabled while the server action
is in progress so again I'm gonna copy
some data over
again you can insert anything you want
here
I already have a title and a description
and an image URL prepared
and I'm going to set the price to
19.99 and now when we click this add
product button it should be disabled and
should show a loading spinner
and this works and after it's done we
get redirected to the front page
and we should see our new data
in the database
and there it is
okay let's add another product and let's
check what actually happens in the
network tab when we execute the server
action
so I want to go to the ads products page
again
add a new product
again I'm gonna copy paste all of this
over
price five dollar
and maybe it's a good idea to disable
the redirect for a moment
so that we keep the data in the network
tab so I'm going to comment this out but
I will add this back later
let's run this with the network tab open
and here we have our add product call
and in the headers tab we can see that
this actually makes a post request to
the same page but this is basically
treated like a server endpoint a post
endpoint so this works just like a
normal server endpoint where we send a
post request tool just like this
endpoint is not on a separate address
it's on the same address as this page
okay let's confirm that this newer
product is also in our database
yeah that is
let's add the redirect back in
and lastly for this section of the
tutorial I want to send up an error page
which will be shown if something goes
wrong in here and we actually throw an
error this should usually not happen
because we have input validation
client-side and Prisma database
operations also don't fail unless the
database is actually down but we should
still have a custom error page and if
you watch my next JS beginner tutorial
then you already know how this works
we put a file with a special name into
the app folder so right click
we have to call it error.tsx this way
next.js automatically turns this into
the error page which will be shown when
something goes wrong for example if a
fetch fails in a server component or a
server action the error page has to be a
client component so we add the US client
directive at the top
and this is always the case for error
TSX and xjs they always have to be in
client components I'm not sure why I
think because of the way the error is
passed to them but they have to be
client components
export default function
let's call it error page again the name
is up to you and here we just want to
return some very simple UI a div that
says
something went wrong
please refresh the page of course you
can make this more sophisticated if you
want
let's actually try this out so let's say
here in our server action we just
pass a test around buzzinga we also have
to comment out this part just for a
moment
and now when we send something here
we should see our error page something
went wrong now I think they are also
planning to add an error field to the
use form status hook so that we can get
the arrow in here and handle it
client-side instead of redirecting to
this error page which can be a bit of a
jarring user experience but right now we
only have the loading state in here
there is no error state in here yet so
the easiest way to handle errors
client-side and server actions is just
to file back to this error page but
again usually the user shouldn't get
there
so let's remove this again
and now that we have some data in our
database we can change our front page
and render our products here right so
let's do that next
okay let's go to the home page which is
the page TSX file that's the direct
child of the app folder
this one here that contains the home
component
and then let's remove all of this crap
here
and set it up from scratch
so we added div and the return block and
then we make this an async function
Remember by default pages in the app
directory are server components unless
we add the use client directive meaning
that we can do a database operations and
all kinds of asynchronous stuff right
inside this component because this will
be executed on the server not on the
client and just like any server action
making database requests and using
credentials and here is also save
because they will not be leaked to the
client this means we can just call
Prisma here so let's create a const
products to fetch all the products from
our database
and assign this to await
Prisma which again we import from our
lip folder
dot product dot find menu
parentheses curly braces and here we can
add a filter or a sort order entry wanna
order products buyer
colon
curly braces and I want to order the
products in descending order so that we
have the newest one at the top
now we could order this by the created
ads timestamp right but it's actually
better to use the idea why because the
ID also contains a timestamp but the ID
is unique reverse theoretically two
products could have the exact same time
stamp so when you want to order
documents in mongodb by that timestamp
it's better to use the idea
colon and then in here we pass the ESC
for descending as a string so now we
order these products by the idea in
descending order with the newest one at
the top
and then we want to render our cards for
each of these products right and for
this again we use Daisy UI
which contains this card component that
we can use so let's go back into our
project let's put it in the components
folder because we want to reuse this in
different places let's call it
product card dot TSX
we export default function as usual with
the same name
this product card will also take a prop
so let's create an interface again you
can use a type or an interface it
doesn't matter but it's usually
recommended to use interface unless you
will need a type we needed to type
earlier tour combine it with component
props but here an interface is enough
let's call it product card props
and each product card will take one
product as input
and the type of this is product with a
capital P we didn't get other completion
but we can get the product type from our
database
through an import from Prisma so import
we destructure this
from at Prisma client
and in here should be the product type
that's coming from our
Prisma schema
the whip has one of these products to
our product card
read this structure this here so that we
can render the information of this
product in this card
for now let's save this and let's render
one of these product cards in our div
just a single one for now so that we can
see the card on the screen while we are
building the UI so in here I'm gonna put
a product card
and for the product for now we just
hardcore the products at the index 0 so
the first element here
again just so that we can see it in the
UI where we are building it
we saved us but we still have to return
UIL from the product card
so let's put a return statement here
I want to make the outer element of this
card a link and next link so that when
we click this card we get forwarded to
the product page
so we are at the next link here
we set the href
to a string
to the page where we will see the
details of this product we haven't set
up this page yet but we will do so later
we will put the URL at slash products
slash
and then we append the product idea
so Auto completion or product idea
and to this link we add the class names
that style this card and I think we also
have to refresh the page here to show
our changes okay the development server
isn't running right now
so I restart this refresh the page again
and we don't see anything yet but we
will see something in a moment
so this link gets
the card class which is coming from this
UI we said W minus full
to make the card take up the full
available width we will later display
this card in a grid
we said BG and base 100 this is the
background color will be a light whitish
color
I also want to set hover
colon Shadow XL this is the class name
implies adds a shadow to our card but we
have this modifier here have a colon it
only applies the shadow when we hover
over the card with the mouse you will
see this in a moment and then we can
also add a transition for the Shadow
with the transition Shadow class
okay let's close this link tag
and in here we render the contents of
the card let's see how this looks if we
just put some text in here for now
this is the card we have our Harbor
Shadow effect but of course this doesn't
look great yet so let's remove text and
instead we add another diff in here
inside the link
with the contents of the cards
we add a class name to this Auto diff
called card minus body
this adds the appropriate padding and
everything to a stylus card body and in
here we put an H2 headline
but again in Tailwind CSS all components
are unstyled by default including
buttons and headlines
so to style this properly we add the
card minus title class
and in here we want to render the name
of the product which we get from the
product object that we pass to this card
okay let's save this see how this looks
already looks better right and we have
the square hover Shadow effect with a
transition you can play around with this
you can try out different styling
different Shadow values but this is fine
for our card here below the H2 I want to
put some more text with the paragraph
tag
in here I want to render product dot
description
which looks like this this is coming
from our database
and then I also want to add a price tag
for this first of all we need to set up
a function that formats the price
properly because remember the price is
just stored in zens but we want to show
it as dollar
we can put this function into the lip
folder here so let's right click on lip
new file let's call it format.ts
and from here we export a function
that we call format price
and to this we will pass the price as a
number
then we want to return the formatted
value on so what we do is we turn the
zens into a dollars first by simply
dividing price by 100.
then we want to format this value in US
dollar which we can do by calling dots
to a local string
as the first argument we have to pass
the local so basically the language to
which we want to format this
and we want to format this to en minus
OS in uppercase like this so we
formatted the string in American English
then we pass a comma and the block of
curly braces where we can do some
configuration
and here we can set the style
to one currency
entries that currency
tour
USD this will take care of formatting
this price properly in US dollar with
the US dollar symbol and the correct
decimal point and whatever I think this
is a bit better than doing it manually
zombies lifters we can also reformat it
with prettier
then I want to create another component
in the components folder
called price tag.tsx again we will reuse
this component in different places
in here we export a default
function
price tag
which will call our format price
function that we just set up
but to this component we are past the
price tag props
which needs the price which again is a
number and again I want to be able to
style this price tag from the outside so
again I add this optional class name
String here that we already saw earlier
and then we pass these props
to the price tag component
and destructure them here
and then down here I want to return
S Pen
which contains the format its price so
between curly braces I call our format
price function which we export from our
lib folder
and to this we simply pass our price
and then we also want to style the span
again with class names from this UI
again we add the back text string here
with curly braces and two back ticks
this UI has this batch class yeah which
states this like a little badge like a
price tag and then we also want to put
our optional class name in here
and that's it for this component
okay let's go back into our product card
and here below the description
I want to render a price tag
and for the price prop we pass product
dot price
okay let's see
the product costs five dollars and this
is rendered by our format function with
the dollar symbol and the decimal point
but of course we also want to render the
image of the product right we do this
above the cardboard here still inside
the card link and in the days the UI
documentation they wrap this image into
a figure I'm not 100 sure wire but it's
best to follow this but in here we don't
use one of these normal HTML images
because in xjs we should usually use the
next image which is an import from next
slash image
because these images are optimized they
are automatically resized by next.js to
the appropriate size and they have some
other cool features that the normal HTML
image doesn't have so for the sr0 so for
the image source we pass product.image
URL this is the image we want to show
for the alt text we can pass
product.name
when we use the next image we have to
set the width and height so next JS
knows at which size it has to load this
image we set this to 800 width
and 400 height now since our cards are
responsive the final dimensions of the
image will actually be defined by CSS
and not by these values here so our
images might not be shown in 800 times
400. this is just the size at which we
load this image so no matter how big the
image is even if it's 4000 pixels next
JS Ray resides it to 800 times 400
pixels and I picked this value because
those are the largest dimensions in
which this image will be shown later if
we would make these Dimensions smaller
then the image would be blurry if we
would make them bigger then we will load
in unnecessarily a large image and to
style this image properly we again add
class names
h48 that's the height of this image in
the cards we want each card and each
card image to have the same height
and then to not make our image distorted
because the dimensions of the image
inside the cards might be different of
the intrinsic Dimensions that the image
file has and to not distort this image
with that object cover
which basically xender crops the image
so if the image is too big or has the
wrong dimensions then it will just be
cut off so it fits into our card image
okay let's save this and there's our
image and again this image changes
depending on the screen size and here
you can see the object cover in action
there's one more thing I want to do in
this product card if the product is
newer I want to add a little batch that
saves newer because this looks cool
so above the return statement in the
product count
we create a const is newer
and here we simply check if date dot now
which is the current timestamp minus we
want to compare it to the created ads
timestamp of the product but this is a
string and to turn this into a date we
have to create a new date
and to this new date Constructor we pass
product dot created at which turns this
into an actual date
and to get the timestamp out of the
state we call Dot get time
and now we can compare to date dot now
which also returns a timestamp and if
the difference between these two is
seven days you can of course also pick
another value then I want to show this
its newer batch so if date.now minus the
date of the created add timestamp is
less than seven days but those values
are milliseconds so we have to calculate
the days 1000 milliseconds
times 60 seconds or one minute times 60
seconds or one hour times 24 hours are
one there times seven for seven days
so now it's newer will be truer if our
product is less than seven days old and
when this is newer we want to render a
little batch which I want to put into
the H2 attack here
after the product name here we put an
expression
if it's new is true to Amazon science
then we want to render another div in
here
that just stays new in all uppercase
and we style this div to a batch with
the batch
and the batch secondary class name which
gives it the secondary color that we set
in our theme
let's save this and there's the batch
our secondary color is this yellow
but now that I see it maybe it would be
better if we don't place it inside the
title right but rather below it maybe
here I think this looks better
so I put it below the H2O attack
so our product card itself is done
but we still want to render these
products in a proper grid right so let's
remove this hard-coded product card here
and I want to render our product as a
grid but I want to render the first
product in the special hero view here
that you saw in the beginning with this
background and this button it just looks
a bit cooler again this is coming from
this UI so let's do it in here in this
first diff we put another div for this
hero viewer
this inner div gets the class names hero
rounded XL which gives this whole
element rounded corners
and BG based 200 for the background
color
and in here we put the next image
which will load the image for the first
product so again products at the first
index
dot image URL
similarly at the IELTS text will contain
the first products name
we set the width to 400 and the height
to 800 but again the final dimensions of
the image will be defined by a CSS those
are just the dimensions to which we
resize the image before we load it
to style this image we add the class
names W foil
we set the max width to SM so that the
image at most has a width of 24 Ram
we make the corners of the image rounded
with rounded LG
to LG and XL and so on are just the
different values for the Border radius
the rounded XL has a border radius of
0.75 RAM and LG has 0.5 Ram this is just
up to your personal preference
and I want to set Shadow 2XL to give
this image a drop shadow
and since this is the first image that
we see on the screen above the fold and
the most important image we add this
priority prop which signals to next.js
that it should load this image first you
should use this on the yeah the largest
image basically that is shown on the
screen
so let's save this and look what we see
here where it doesn't look great yet we
still need to show the product
information and align this properly what
we do is we wrap this image into another
div
so a third diff right here we put a
closing tag below the image
and restyle this div here
with the class names hero minus content
Flex call to make this a flexbox column
where the elements are aligned below
each other
but then we also write LG colon
Flex row and this is how you create
responsive layouts in Tailwind CSS
because this means on small screens this
will be a flex column so the elements
will be aligned below each other but as
soon as we get to the LG break point
which is a screen break point so a
certain size of our screen then we use a
flex row instead meaning that the
elements will be a aligned horizontally
instead of vertically so again whatever
modifier we use here will be applied on
larger screens and upwards and whatever
we use with auto modifier will be used
on small screens and we don't have to
add a modifier for small screens here
because this LG modifier basically means
greater than or equal to one so if the
screen is greater than or equal to LG
then we will always use a flex row and
if it's below that then we will use a
flex call this needs a bit getting used
to but this is how you create responsive
layouts in Tailwind
and then right below the image but
inside this inner div we put another div
for the text of this hero item
this doesn't need any styling
but in here we put in H1
that we start with text5 XL
which sets the text size
we use Font bold which is
self-explaining and in this H1 we want
to render the name of the first product
right so again products at the index 0
dot name
and there's the title of this hero
element and since the screen is so small
right now and we are zoomed in this Flex
coil is applied right but if I make this
window big then Flex row is applied and
these elements are aligned horizontally
and on small screens they are aligned
vertically you can also see this switch
here when we reach this breakpoint
and again this breakpoint is defined by
this LG colon you can see in the
Tailwind documentation what exact pixel
its value this breakpoint has you can
also modify this but this is not
necessary for us okay let's finish the
diff down here below the H1 we put a P
tag
which we give some vertical padding
which we can do with py minus six why is
the vertical axis for horizontal padding
you can use PX
and again and here we render products at
the index 0 Dot
description
and there it is
and then I want to add a button that
brings us to the product page
below the paragraph tag we put the next
link
make sure it Imports the next link
we set the href of the slink tour
slash products the same UI we used
earlier
slash and then the ID of this first
product so products at the index 0
dot idea
and we want to render this link like a
button but you shouldn't make it a
button first of all because this is a
server component and we can't handle
Clicks in a server component but also
when we link to another page then we
should actually render a link and not a
button element it can look like a button
but it should be a link which is
important for accessibility you always
want to use the correct HTML element but
again we can style this as a button with
BTN and BTN
primary
and then we close this link
and here the link of course doesn't
contain any text yet
which we add between the linked tags
check it out for example
okay so this is now a link that looks
like a button which brings us to the
product page that we haven't set up yet
and again this is responsive so on
larger screens it looks like this on
smaller screens it looks like this
and below this hero item we want to
render the grid with the remaining items
just have to see in which diff we want
to put this we want to put this below
the hero diff here so below this one
inside the outer div
in here we put another div
which we render as CSS grid again with
Tailwind class names
first off I will set my
-4 which is a vertical margin again m
stands for margin and y stands for the
vertical axis so top and bottom we want
to render a grid Drifter grid class
and then we Define how many columns the
squared should have and again this
depends on the screen size right so we
use different breakpoints we start with
grit coils 1 for one column
which will be applied on small screens
on a medium sized screens MD colon
we want to set create calls to Tool so
we show two columns on slightly larger
screens
and then we add the third breakpoint XL
and I figure this out by just playing
around with different break points and
see when it looks good
on Notch screens we want to show three
columns
and to add some space between the Zinger
cards in the script we can add the gap
for our class
so those are all the classes we add here
then we close this div
and render the actual product cards in
here we already have the product card
component set up right so here we can
now put an expression we want to render
all our products in here except for the
first one because we already rendered
the first one here in this hero view so
what we do is we call products dot slice
and pass the index one this way we turn
a new array without the first element
and then we want to take each of these
product objects and map them to a
product card right
so in here we get past each product not
produced but product
and after the right arrow we add
parentheses and in here we want to
render a product card for each product
if you don't know what map does then you
probably haven't worked with react
before and you have to watch a beginner
tutorial first but this way we turn each
of these products in the array into a
product card that we can then render in
the UI the product card expects the
product object
which we get passed by the map function
and when we render a list we also have
to set the keyer this is required for
react to a re-render lists efficiently
and here we have to set a unique value
for which we can use the unique idea of
the product and then we close this
and when we save this there's our grid
right now we only have three products in
total so let's add some more
over the edge products page
so I'm gonna go ahead and add a few more
products but I will skip this part in
this video because you already know how
this works just go ahead and add a few
more products so that we can show
something in our grid
so I went ahead and added some more
products and now we can see our full
grid doesn't it look beautiful and each
card has a hover Shadow and when we
click the card we get to The Details
page of this product which doesn't exist
yet and this grid is fully responsive so
on larger screens we have three columns
when we make the screen smaller we get
to two columns and eventually to one and
this is the largest width at which our
card images are displayed and this is
around
700 something pixels as you can see up
here
this is why I set the width of the image
in the product card to 800. this way we
make sure that we always have an image
that is large enough but not too large
when we open one of these images in a
new tab you can see that the width is
approximately 800 pixels which again is
the largest size at which we need this
image
which is shown when we only have one
column okay later we will also add
pagination to this page so that we
download all products at once and as a
reminder by default server components in
react are statically cached meaning that
all these products are fetched when we
compile the project here in our server
component and then even if we reload the
page after we added new products we
won't show these new products at least
not in production in order to always
show the newest products we have to
revalidate this page but this will not
be necessary when we later add the
search param for the page that we are
currently on because as soon as we add
search params to a server component in
xjs it's automatically dynamically
rendered but don't worry if this is
confusing to you right now you will see
how this works later
okay since we are already linking to our
products detail page through our cards
here let's set up this product detail
page next so we go into our project and
remember the URL for our products page
was Slash products slash and then the ID
of the product
so in the app folder we create a new
folder and again I explain how this
routing structure works in my next js13
beginner tutorial
we want to have a folder called products
and then here we want another folder
where we put the ID of the product
because this is part of the URL
so slash products slash idea
and finally in here we put a file
page.tsx to render a page at this path
so let's set up the props for this page
product page props
and in here we want to get the ID out of
the URL so that we can use this idea to
load the correct product from our
database right
and we get this over the params value
because params will contain
the ID placeholder that we put into our
path here
suprams is another object which contains
the idea which is a string and then we
can pass this to our page component
which then loads the product
so we export a default async function
here
which we call product page
and it takes the product page props
in which we can find the params and we
destructure this further with a colon
and a pair of curly braces and in here
is the idea right
and this is a normal server component so
we can make our database requests
directly in here
we create a const product
we call await Prisma
dot product
dot find unique
and this allows us
to find a product by its idea in
parentheses and curly braces we write
real colon
add another pair of curly braces and in
here we pass the idea
so we want to find a single product
where the idea is the same as the ID we
pass in the URL now the product we get
back from this find card can be null
because it might be the case that the
product with this ID doesn't exist right
and in this case we don't want to render
an empty page instead we want to forward
the user to do 404 not found page we
already saw this not found the page
earlier when we just enter any road that
doesn't exist by default it looks like
this but this is not great for one it's
not styled at all but also no elements
that we put into our root layout is
shown on this 404 page so when we later
put enough bar in the footer in here
this navbar and folder will not be shown
on the 404 page and it's a really bad
user experience because they don't have
anything to click they just see this
empty page but if you watched my next.js
13 beginner tutorial then you know that
we can overwrite this not found page and
show our own one which will be rendered
inside our root layout here so let's do
that next
for this we are add another file to the
app folder
which we call not minus found.tsx and
again as for IDs special files the
naming of the file is important because
only this way next.js will recognize
this as the 404 page this page will be
very simple we export a simple component
that we call not found or not found page
the name of the component itself doesn't
matter
and here we simply return a div that
says
page not found
again you can make this more
sophisticated but I want to keep it
simple here now when we open a page that
doesn't exist it renders our own not
found page and later our navbar in our
photo will also be shown here
so I know with this note found page in
place we can also redirect to it
dynamically which we want to do if our
product is now
for this we check if exclamation mark
product
so that's now undefined
then we call this not found function
which is an import from next slash
navigation again this redirects us to
the not found page the same one we see
here on the left side but only if
product is null and Below we can now
render our products page because we know
that the product now has a value
so in the return block we render a div
and we add some class names to this diff
we want to make this a flexbox
we want to render a flex column by
default
but again on LG screens and larger
we want to render a flex row instead to
make this responsive
and inside the div we put the product
image and then the name and the
description
so in here we put a next image make sure
it's adding the correct import
we set sr0
to the image URL of the product we
loaded up here
similarly we set the alt text
to the name of the product
we set the width and the height
above to 500.
but 10 CSS actually that's the final
height of the image to the intrinsic
height the image file has for example if
the image has a width of 500 and a
height of 200 then the image we see on
the screen will also be 500 times 200
and when next.js resizes an image I
think it only takes the width into
account the height doesn't really matter
only to reserve space so even if the
real height of the image is larger than
500 then this will still work it will
only resize it to have the appropriate
width anyway if you just use these
values here then it will work and I want
to add some rounded Corners to this
image because this looks better
which we do a rounded LG again and again
this is the largest image and the only
image shown on this page so we set the
priority attribute
and below this image still inside this
div we put another div for the product
text
we set the H1
to the product name
and we style this H1
with text 5 XL which again that's the
font size
and we make it bold again
below the product name I want to render
a price tag instead we already set up
this component earlier
and for the price we pass
product.price right
and to the price tag we can pass an
optional class name which we want to do
now because I also want to add some
Mulch and top with mt minus 4 to this
price tag
and Below we put the product description
which is just a paragraph tag
products dot description
entry at the p y minus 6 class name to
add some vertical padding
okay let's save this and let's navigate
to a product page
there it is
responsive
but we still need some gap between the
text and the image
but we already move between a flex
column and a flex row at the appropriate
break point
to get some room between the image and
the text we use Gap 4 and GAP is better
to use than a margin here because a gap
will work no matter if it's a flex
column or a flex row this way we don't
have to decide between a margin top or a
margin and for example
so now we get some space here which also
works on larger screens and I also want
to send out this text here but only when
we have a flex row right so only on
larger screens
so we add LG colon
items sender item Center is the class
for a line item Center in CSS
and now it should look good
now it looks like this on larger screens
but it's responsive and it even gets
smaller on small screens until we reach
the Min width which we set with 300
pixels earlier
okay and I also want to set the metadata
of this page by this time I don't want
to hot coat the title and the
description instead I want the title to
contain the product name and the
description to contain the description
of the product if we want to generate
the metadata dynamically we don't export
this metadata value that we used earlier
instead we have to export another
function
outside of the products page component
we export another async function called
generate metadata and the spelling of
the function name has to be correct
again otherwise next.js were not
recognized as
this will return a metadata object which
is an import from next again
and by defining the return value here we
get Auto completion when we later
construct this metadata object but since
this is an async function we have to
wrap this return value into a promise
because all async functions return the
promise why do I make this an async
function well we actually have to fetch
the same product from the database in
this function here as well in order to
get the name and the description of the
product we actually can't share data
between the page and generate metadata
we have to fetch the product in both
places but now you might say isn't it
wasteful to fetch the data from the
database trials and of course it's
wasteful this is why we have to Cache
this product that we get from our
database so that we only fetch it once
this is done for you automatically only
if you use the fetch function that we
have in JavaScript if you use fetch to
fetch data from some API then this is
cached and deduplicated for you
automatically however if we use
something like Prisma or XC yours or
anything else to fetch our data then we
have to Cache it manually if you don't
do this then we actually do a two
database operations and this of course
is very wasteful if you want to confirm
this then you can try out fetching the
data here twice and lock your database
operations
which we can do by passing
lock to our Prisma client here but I
don't remember what you have to pass for
the value you have to look this up in
the documentation this allows you to
lock all your database operations and
then you can see that this is executed
twice but I already did this so I can
confirm it for you in order to
de-duplicate this request we have a
cache function from react which is also
pretty new so what we do is we create a
const
that we can get product
and then we call this cache function
here which is coming from react
to Cache we can pass another async
function and the return value of this
async function repairs here will be
cached and here we basically want to
execute this part we want to fetch our
product from the database and then
return it and for this we need the ID of
the product right
so in here this editing function that we
pass
will take one argument the IDS string
and then we create an error function
like this with a right arrow and a block
of curly braces so now we pass this
function to the react cache function and
in here we can simply cut out this part
put it in here
and then we simply return this product
and now down here where we had this
function before
we create a const product again
but this time we call a weight get
product which is this cached function up
here
and we pass the product ID into this
function now we still get the same
product but it's coming from this cached
value here and now we can do the same
and generate metadata and this way this
will only be executed once and this
value will be shared between these two
functions we still need a product ID and
generate metadata right and this can
actually take the same props as the page
so we pass this in here
and then we only have to return the
metadata that we now can generate from
this product information okay so we
return a JavaScript object and again
since we added this return value here we
now get Auto completion for example we
can set the title just as we did before
but now we can generate the title from
the product name and then I want to
append this Dash
flomas on that's behind it
like this
I also want to set the meta description
to the product description and again we
can see this later when we post a link
to our website on social media and we
will actually do this we will actually
deploy our project and then I will show
you these previews and I also want to
overwrite the open craft image so the
image that is shown on social media by
default that's this open graph image
file that I put in the starting code but
we can overwrite this dynamically for a
specific page and I want to show the
product image instead for this we can
add this open graph value to the
metadata
which again takes a JavaScript object
and here we can pass images colon we
pass an array
this array contains another block of
curly braces and here we can set the URL
to a product dot image URL
again we can't see this right now
because yeah only the title is shown
here in the browser we have to refresh
the page and that does Thornhill slices
but you will later see these other
values after we have deployed our
project okay on this product page I also
want to put the button that allows us to
add this product to the cart but before
we do this I want to create the loading
page again I explain this in my next JS
beginner tutorial the loading page will
be shown when we open a server component
and it's still loading because we are
fetching all this data before we
actually show this page on the screen
right this is Alf hatched server side
not client-side which means that it can
take a while before the page is shown
and to not make it feel unresponsive to
the user we can add the loading page
that will be shown while a page is
loading
we put this right in the app folder and
again the name has to be exact
loading.tsx
and in here we export
a simple component again
which we call loading page or loading
and from here I want to return another
spell
with the class names loading which again
is coming from this UI
loading dots is a different kind of
loading indicator
then the size
loading LG
M Oro which send us this loading
indicator horizontally on the screen
and the last class I want to set is
block which sets this to display block
this is necessary for M order to work
and then we close this and then we have
our loading page we should see this in
action if we go to the front page again
yeah there it was for a short moment but
when we click a product we should also
see the loading page while the product
is loading
it wasn't there yeah I think we don't
see it because nextjs pre-fetches these
pages but you see it when we refresh the
front page right but this will also be
shown sometimes when we open a product
page or another page okay and the next
step is to create the actual shopping
cart in our database and add a button
with which we can add products to our
cart really exciting okay the next step
is to add our shopping cart model to our
database so that we can actually put
products in there
so let's go into our schema.prisma file
again and we could make the changes in
the database first and then use
introspection again to change the schema
here but it's actually easier to do it
the other way around to modify the
schema and then push the changes to our
database so below our product model we
create a new model which we call a card
so model card curly braces each model in
our database needs an idea so let's copy
the ID line from the product model and
paste it here
this does the same it creates an idea
automatically for us of type
object idea
and we can also copy these two
timestamps here so that we know when we
created and last updated a card and for
the items we put in the cards we create
yet another model model which we call
card item
and we ignore this error message here
for now now we could also put the card
items as an array directly into the card
document but this makes it harder to
work with because then we always have to
fetch the whole array when we want to
modify it even if we just want to change
the quantity of a single item also
documents in mongodb have a size
constraint meaning that we can't make
this card item array grow indefinitely
now in practice this is probably not a
problem but it's still good practice to
put these card items into a separate
collection in my opinion so again each
card item needs an idea so we copy paste
this line This is the ID of the document
itself and each card item also needs the
ID of the product it references right so
we know which product is in the card so
we create another field below product
idea and don't worry about the alignment
right now we will reformat this file at
the end
this is also of type string and it's a
mongodb object idea so we write the same
as here at the end of the ID line at DB
Dot
object idea but this product ID is not
order generated like the ID of the
document itself this is just the ID of
the product we put in there then we also
need the quantity so we know how many of
these products we put into the card
which will be of type int
and we need the ID of the cards that
this card item belongs to and a card
then belongs to a user
so we add another field below card idea
which again is a string that contains a
DB dot object ID
okay let's format the document to align
everything properly again on the nose
that's shift IDF if you are on Mac or
Linux you can also search for the format
document shortcut here
but right now we are just storing these
ideas it's also useful if we tell Prisma
what model these IDs belong to because
this makes it easier later to work with
for this we can use relations so what we
do is below the product idea
we also write product
which will be of type product and
product is our product model up here
then we write add relation
and between the parentheses we write
Fields colon pair of scrap brackets
and then we pass our product ID on which
is this field up here that contains the
idea of the product
after the closing square bracket we
write comma references let me make this
big
idea that's the ID field of the product
here so that we know that one product
idea is connected to a the ID of the
product and now when we press the
formatting shortcut I think Prisma
should add something to the product
model as well and of course reformat our
code so shift IDF and it added this card
item array to our product model this is
the counterparts to this line down here
so they always belong together because
now that each card item references a
product we can also fetch all card items
that contain a product through the
product model and if we deleted this
line then we actually get an error
because they always belong together
and then we want to do the same for the
card so we store the card ID here which
belongs to a card document in our
database So Below we write card
off type card
and again add relation
which Fields does it reference the card
idea
which belongs to the idea in the card
model again we press the formatting
shortcut and it adds this line to the
card model and this one here is
especially useful because this allows us
to fetch all the card items with all
their product information that belong to
a particular card this is important
later to fetch the whole card with
arlet's data but I want to rename this
field I want to color adjust items and
put it here above the timestamps
and I also want to rename the
collections again lowercase and plural
because that's convention for mongodb so
again below we write add add map and the
name of the collection which will be
cards
and the same for the card items here
since they are their own model they live
in their own collection
card items in our lowercase
one more thing we go to our product
relation in the card item again after
the references field
write comma
on delete in camera case like this and
then Cascade with an uppercase C
what this does is if we delete a product
all the card items that contain this
product will also automatically be
deleted because we can't have an item in
our cards for a product that doesn't
exist anymore right that's it with the
changes in our model for now so again
let's reformat this let's save it and
then we have to push the changes to our
database so we open the terminal
and stop the execution of our Dev
environment then again as I mentioned in
the beginning we run npx
Prisma DB push
which pushes these new changes to our
database here you can see what it does
it created two new collections for the
cards and the card items so let's take a
look into our database here here we have
two new collections
and if we set up any special indexes
also in our model then this will also
push to the database with npxdb push but
right now of course these collections
are emptier so let's go back into our
project
and then we also run npx Prisma generate
to regenerate our Prisma client so that
we have our new models available on the
Prisma object and can make database
operations so now when we take a look
at the place where we use our Prisma
client like here for example and use all
the completion we now have the card and
the card item here available as well
this is what Prisma generate does it
creates a newer Prisma client with the
correct schema inside it
okay let's run the development
environment again
and then we want to add a button to our
product detail page to add this product
to our cart and then we want to put this
button on our product detail page here
below the description
but this time I also want to have a
success message so after we added a
product to the card I won't have a
little text that there's a product edit
or something like that but the use form
status that we are used in our form
submit button here
only contains this loading state it
doesn't contain a success State at least
not yet they might add this in the
future but for now we have to handle the
success State ourselves and since this
is State we can only do this in a client
component because only a client
component can contain State this is why
this time we can't execute our server
action in a server component but what we
can do is we can wrap all of this logic
into the button itself so that only the
button has to be a client component and
the product page itself can stay a
server component because again server
components are more efficient since we
will only use this button on this page
let's put it not in the components
folder but right here in the product ID
folder right next to the page itself
because in the next JS app router we can
co-locate these files with the pages
we call it adds tour card button dot TSX
and then in here we create a client
component
with the same name
to this add to cards button we will add
the ID of the product that this button
belongs to so we create an interface for
the props
and in here we put the product idea
in form of a string
and then we pass this
to the component
and then let's set up the layout of this
button so we put the return block here
we wrap this all into a diff because
next to the button will be the success
message
and to align them properly we set the
class name to flex
items Center and GAP tour for some
spacing
and into the diff we put the button
itself
which we Style with BTN
BTN primary
we set an on-click Handler on this
button but for now we just pass an empty
Arrow function like this because we will
take care of this later
then we close this button tag and set
the text to add to cart
before we continue let's save this and
put this button into our layout to see
how it looks so on the product ID page
we put the button below the description
add to a card button
and for the product idea we pass the ID
of the product that we load on this page
and there's our button
I also want to put an icon in here a
shopping cart icon and I have to copy
paste this because this is an SVG
there it is again I will link this in
the description below and you can copy
it from there you can also leave this
out for now it doesn't matter the text
here is enough and now again we want to
handle this action via a server
component because this way we don't have
to set up an API route Handler and
instead we can just call a function in
our code right here but we can't declare
server actions inside client components
so we can't put the action directly here
into this file however you can still
import server actions into Clan
components that's possible you just have
to declare the server action in a
separate file so let's put this file
into the same folder here in the
products idea route
new file and the naming convention for
this is usually just actions but you can
give this any name you want and here we
put the server actions that belong to
this route
remember when we created the server
action on the add product page we use
this use server directive here at the
start of the function
since this file will only contain the
other actions we can put this all the
way at the top this way we only have to
declare at one time and not in each
function if we added multiple functions
to this file okay and then we export an
async function
let's call it increment
product quantity because this is what
this function does right
and it takes the product idea as an
argument
and I have a very nastier typo here at
product quantity No it should be correct
in here we want to fetch the cards or
create one if it doesn't exist yet but
we haven't set up functions that let us
create or modify a card yet and since we
want to work with our cards from
different places we don't put these
database functions right in here we put
them into a separate file so that we can
reuse them
this time we put them into the lip
folder and here into a Debian let's
create a new file called
card.ts so here we put database
operations on our card that we want to
reuse in different places but those are
not server actions those are just
functions we use in our server actions
so we don't have to put the your server
directive here at the top let's start
with the function that creates a new
account so export async function
create card
doesn't take any arguments and in here
we create a const new card
and then we call away to Prisma which
again we import from the Prisma file in
the lib folder
Dot card
dot create I think this is safe
explaining
and we want to create an empty cart so
for data we just pass an emptier pair of
curly braces because we don't want to
put any data in there yet we just want
to create an empty cart but it will
contain the timestamps now later when
the user is logged in we can connect our
cards to a user account but if the user
is not logged in we also want to support
Anonymous cards right but how do we
later find this card in the database how
do we know that the user belongs to a
certain card if they are not logged in
for this we will store the ID of the
card in a cookie in the browser of the
user and later we can read this cookie
to get the correct card again and we can
do this with this cookies function from
next.js we can call this with
parentheses and then we have this set
function there
and then we give this cookie a name I'm
gonna call it local card idea but you
can give it any name you want
and in here we want to store newcart.id
and as simple as that we can set a
cookie now in production you should make
this more secure you should encrypt the
card idea because a user can modify the
cookies and this way they could just
guess the idea of another card and if
they are successful they could change
the contents of the card of another user
theoretically of course the damage of
doing this is lower but in a real
production app you should take care of
this and the cookie itself also needs
some additional security settings but I
skipped this step here for Simplicity
because it doesn't really add anything
to this tutorial and it only matters if
you really want to deploy this eCommerce
website to production otherwise this
here is enough and I will leave a
comment as a reminder so if you are
interested in this you can look this up
and Google those are just some
additional steps you have to do but it
shouldn't be too complicated
and then we also want to create a
function that gets the card from the
database you can put it above or below
does metal
export async function get card again it
doesn't take any arguments here we want
to get the card idea out of the cookie
because we are still working with
Anonymous cards
so let's create a const local card idea
cookies dot get this time
and we of course pass the same cookie
name as a string
and out of this we can get a value
this can be undefined because the cookie
might not exist this is where it adds
the safe call operator and Below we
create a const card
equals
we can only fetch the card if we have
the local card idea so if it is defined
it's a rewrite local cut idea question
mark to use the ternary operator
if the local card ID is defined
we want to assign the cars to a weight
make our database operation so press my
DOT card dot find unique to find the
card by its idea
then we add the swear clause
where idea colon
is the same as the local cut idea from
the cookie and then we can do something
really cool so by default the card
doesn't contain the card items right
because we don't store them as an array
in the card model they are in a separate
collection similarly the card items
don't store the product information the
products are also in their own
collection and this is really important
because if we update the information of
a product for example the price or the
description then we also want these
changes to be reflected in the card
items and in the card right we don't
want any stale data in our card because
this would be a terrible user experience
instead we fetch this product
information only when we need it but
when we make our query here we can tell
Prisma to put the card item information
into the cards that we fetch from the
database and put the product information
into the card items and it works like
this after where we put a comma
and then we add include colon curly
braces
then in here we have items which refers
to
items field here in the cards model
now we could write column true this way
we would put the card items into the
card that we fetch from the database but
remember that the card items don't
contain the product information yet only
the product idea to go one level deeper
we don't pass through instead we pass
another block of curly braces
and in here we can write include again
to include the product information into
the cut items so again include colon
and in here we have the product
and then we set this to true
this might look a bit complicated at
first but other completion helps you
here so just press Ctrl space or command
space and you will see what you can
include and what operators you can use
but again this way we don't only fetch
the cards with the ID and the timestamp
we also put the card item information in
there and we put the product information
into the cut items so now we have our
full card with all the latest product
information inside
but we are using the ternary operator
here so we also need a colon afterwards
let's put it here if the local card ID
is missing we want to return null here
because then we can't fetch a card
this is below we check if exclamation
mark card if it's null
then we want to return null from this
function
and if the card exists we want to return
the card
but I don't only want to return the card
I also want to return some additional
meta information I want to return how
many items there are in the cart right
now and what's the current subtotal of
all the prices combined so we don't just
return the cart we return a block of
curly braces to create a new JavaScript
object and here we first of all spread
the card to put all the card information
in there and then we add additional
Fields one is the desires and for this
we have to do a little calculation
because we can't just use cuts.length
because we don't store a separate card
item for each item we put into our cart
instead we always have a product and a
quantity so we have to calculate the
size we can do this with cart dot items
dot reduce is just a JavaScript function
and this takes another function as an
argument where we get the accumulated
value
and the next item in the list and then
we can calculate the total quantity for
this we take azzm but this is just a
naming convention you can name this
anything you want
plus item dot quantity so it goes
through each element in our array and it
adds the quantity to the accumulated
value so that we get the total quantity
at the end and that's the second
argument after a comma we have to pass
the starting value I think which is zero
okay so again reduce is just a normal
JavaScript function that you can use for
stuff like this
and then we also want to add the
subtotal
for which again we use the reduce
function card dot items
dot reduce
again we get the accumulated value and
the next item
and then we want to make our calculation
acz Plus
item dot quantity
and we want to multiply this with the
price of the product right to get the
total price
item dot product dot price
and again comma
and zero as the starting value
now it would be cool if we had a type
for this object because we want to
return an empty card from create card as
well with the same structure and it's
always good to set up a type so that we
get Auto completion and we know what
Fields belong in there right we can
create the type above we could also put
it in another file but it's closely
connected to these functions so I think
it makes sense to put them here
we don't use an interface we use a type
because again I want to combine two
types with an intersection and I'm going
to call it shopping count
shopping cart and not just cards because
card is already the name of the card
model in the database
we want to use this card and combine it
with the size and the subtotal that we
add down here so we add an Amazon sign
to create this intersection type
and then a block of curly braces and
then here we put the size
of type number
and subtotal of type number
there's just one problem this card type
here only contains the data that is in
the card model the ID and the timestamps
it doesn't contain the card item or
product information and by default press
my doesn't give us this populated type
we have card item but this is not
populated with the product information
but we can create these types ourselves
and Prisma has convenience functions
that we can use for that so above the
shopping carts type
we export another type and we export
them so that we can use them in
different files later let's call it card
with products because that's the card
with all the product information in
there
and then we can use Prisma with an
uppercase Pier we have to import this
dots can't get payload
and then we add a pair of angle brackets
like this in between the angle brackets
we put a block of curly braces and then
we add the same include query that we
also have down here
and we paste them between these curly
braces and this creates this type from
this Caribbean so now we have a card
with all the populated items in there
that contain the product information
and then we can use this down here as
the type for our shopping cart and now
we have a shopping cart with all the
data inside it and this additional size
and subtotal value and this is the same
structure of the object we return here
so let's add an explicit return type to
get card this is just a good convention
so that you make sure that you always
return the correct object so after I get
card rewrite colon and again we have to
wrap this into a promise because this is
an async function
and we return a shopping cart or another
if the cookie is missing and then as I
said we also want to return an empty
shopping cart from create card so that
we can work with it
so we add a return type here as well
again a promise of type shopping cart
and we get an error because we are not
returning anything yet we will do that
below after we set the cookie we return
an object and now since we defined this
return type we get Auto completion here
which is really useful the card
information so the ID of the card and
the timestamps are contained in this new
card object right so we spread this in
here just like we did for the other card
above
for the size we simply pass zero because
the new card is emptier and for subtotal
as well just so that we have a cut to
work with in our app but this day
complains because the data of this card
is emptier so for items we just add an
empty array
okay let's format and save those and
then we can use these functions in our
server action file
in increment product quantity here we
want to fetch the card from the database
so that we can modify it so we create a
const card
equals
a weight get card which is the new
function we just created
but if we get back now here we want to
create a new card because a card might
not exist yet if we open the website we
don't create a card immediately we only
create it when we actually modify the
card so that we don't bloat our database
with empty Anonymous cards so we add two
question marks which means that the
right side will be executed if get card
returns null or undefined
then we want to await create card
and this also gives us a new card back
right just an empty card when we
reformat this file prettier
automatically adds parentheses around
these cards but I think they should not
be necessary the logic should be the
same this is probably just for
readability so now we have our card and
when we click our add to cart button we
either want to add this product to the
card if it doesn't exist or if it's
already in the card we want to increase
the quantity so we check if the article
is already in the card let's create a
const article in cart equals
and then we want to find this item in
card.items so we can use the find
function which again is just a normal
JavaScript function
this passes us each item in this array
and then we can check if an item with
this product ID is already in the card
so we check item dot product ID which
remember is part of this schema so each
card item contains the product ID and
that it references if this product idea
is the same
as the product idea that we passed to
this increment quantity function then we
know that this item is already in the
card and then we want to increase its
quantity if not we want to put a newer
item into the card
So Below we check
if article in cut
we want to update the quantity of the
existing card item so we call a weight
Prisma which again we have to import
Dot card item dot update to which as
usual we pass curly braces
here we first have to type Prisma which
item we want to update with this where
keyer to which again repairs curly
braces and in here we have the idea
that we compare to an article and cut
dot idea because this is the one we want
to update right
comma and as the second value we pass
the data of this update
as usual we get Auto completion here we
want to update the quantity
again curly braces and then we have this
increment value that we can use
we want to increment this by one now we
could also update it with the current
quantity plus one this would have the
same effect however I think increment
avoids race conditions if you updated
from relatively places but this
shouldn't make any difference here
because no user will update their card
from many different places at once right
but if we have this increment function
available then we might as well use it
okay so we increment the product
quantity of the existing cards in the
else block if the item is not in the
card yet then we want to create a new
card item
so we call a weight Prisma Dot card item
dot create this time
and here we only have to pass the data
we want to set the card idea
to the idea of the cards that we are
fetched again the card ideas part of our
card item model here
so that we know which card this item
belongs to so we set a card idea
then we want to set the product idea of
the product we are adding
now instead of writing product ID column
product idea we can also use the short
syntax if the value has the same name as
the key
and we want to set the quantity to one
but there's one more thing we want to do
here after this operation is done we
want to refresh the screen so that we
see the latest number of items in our
cards in Enough by later for example but
we are working mostly with server
components so we don't have any state in
there that we can update instead we can
refresh the whole screen basically and
the way this works in server actions is
you call revalidate path with the path
that you want to refresh which will
fetch the latest data
string
off the path we want to update we want
to update the slash products slash scrap
records and the idea like this
this is the path of the product page
right we have app products and ID and
scrap records and this is the path we
want to refresh notice that this string
contains the path and not the URL so we
put the same ID between square brackets
and here as we also have in the folder
name because this is not the actual URL
this is the path it has in our file
structure
and later when we use this server action
this line here will take care that the
screen refreshes with the latest data
and we want to call This Server action
in our add to cart button right now
normally we could just import the server
action here and use it in here this
works even when this is a client
component however there is currently a
bug that makes this approach not work
with next off that we will later
Implement later we will not only have
the anonymous card right we will also
fetch the current user session when we
get the card from the database and this
currently doesn't work in server
components that you import directly into
client components this is a bug they
will eventually fix this but for us
right now this means that we can't
import our server action right here in
this adds to cut button component but
what we can do instead is we can import
it in the server component so the page
itself and then we can pass the server
action as a prop to the adds to cart
button so we just pass it as another
argument just like the product idea so
let's do it like this let's add another
argument to the props
which we give the same name as The
Silver function we just set up
increment product quantity the name
doesn't have to match but it makes sense
because this is what we expect right
so this is a function that takes in the
product idea and it doesn't return
anything
so we write it like this
colon product idea of type string and
the return value of the function is a
promise of type void promise again
because it's an async function
then we'll
add this function down here where we
destructure the props
and then we want to call those when we
click the button right
so inside this on click block
now the documentation about server
actions state that when you call them
from a client component you should wrap
them into a use transition use
transition is a relatively newer react
hook which you can look up if you want
but they don't really expand in the
documentation why we have to use that
here it's not really clear they just
explained that we have to use it I spend
a lot of time trying to figure out why
because this is not really explained
anywhere yet at the moment but I
eventually got an answer on Twitter so I
asked here
and Tim is part of the next JS team so
he should know start transition bounds
the error that happened in the
transition to the component where your
card use transition this ensures that
server actions when cut manually Do Not
Crash the entire page so in a nutshell
this means that we have to wrap this
into a stats transition so that any
error that happens in the server action
is forwarded to our own error page which
I think we haven't set up yet but we
will do this later in other words the
error is handled properly and doesn't
crash our app and also when we use start
transition we get this loading State
here that we can use to show a loading
indicator so let's go back into our
project and implement this so we need
this use transition hook that we can
initialize here at the top so const and
it returns a topic just like you said
the first value is usually called is
pending which is true while this
transition is running
and the second argument is usually
called start transition you can give
this any name you want but those are
naming conventions and then we
initialize this with this us transition
hook which is a react import normally
the purpose of use transition is to not
block the UI when we do a state updates
but this doesn't really have anything to
do with our server actions here again in
our case this use transition is
necessary because we call a server
action from a client component and this
takes care of handling the error and the
loading State properly this is what I
showed you a moment ago
but I also want to create a second state
when our operation was successful we
want to show a little message right
so we create another toolbar that
contains the success and set success
and we assign this to a U.S state not
use transition this time but use State
make sure that it adds the correct
import and re-initialize your state with
faults which automatically infers this
as a Boolean
and then in the on-click Handler of our
button first of all we want to set
success back to false to hide the
success message when we click the add to
cart button again then we want to call
the server action and again we have to
wrap this into a start transition which
is this part that we get here
this is a function that takes another
function as an argument in here we write
async and add another arrow function
like this
async because we want to await our
increment product quantity function
which is an async function this one here
we call it weight
increment product quantity
and pass the ID of the product so this
is our server action that we pass to the
clan component and then after this is
done we want to set success to true to
show the success message this is all
happening inside start transition
okay so now we have a loading stage
through its pending and we have a
success date from our use date now let's
render a loading spinner and a success
message in the UI when these values are
true
we do this below the button but still
inside the stiff and we already styled
this div to a flexbox that centers the
items so this should be aligned
correctly
and here we put an expression with curly
braces and first we check if s pending
is true
then we want to render a loading
indicator which again we do with a span
that gets a safe closing tag
and for the class name we use Daisy UI
classes as we did earlier loading to
turn this into a loading indicator
and loading spinner yeah to make it a
loading spinner and we can set the size
with loading minus MD
and then another one below this time we
want to check if success is true to show
the success message but success will
actually be true before we have
revalidated the path so before we
reloaded the page which remember we do
in our server action we can't revalidate
path here and this happens after the
server action has finished however this
is pending value will be true until the
revalidation finished so what we do is
we combine these two values down here we
check that is pending is back to false
with exclamation mark is pending
and success is true
only then we want to render the success
message
which again we put into a spin
it will say added to cart
you can add any text you want
and reset the class name to attack
success which again is a this UI class
that just gives us a green color
okay and now we only have to pass our
server action from our page to our add
to cart button and one more time to
recap normally we can import server
actions in client components this is not
a problem but here we have to pass it as
an argument because there's currently a
little bug that happens when we later
use next off to get the locked in user
session this is where we passed the
server action as an argument instead
so to add to cart button we have to pass
increment product quantity
which we import from the actions file
and then we should be all set up to try
this out
let's refresh the page just to make sure
when we click the add to cart button we
should see a loading spinner for a short
moment and then we should see a success
message right add to cart as the loading
spinner added to card now there was a
little glitch when the page reloaded but
this glitch only happens in development
because it's reloading the font for some
reason but in production there is no
glitch so it doesn't look as if we just
refresh the page instead the image and
the text will just stay in place and
only the parts that have to be updated
will refresh with the latest data but
there is no glitch in the UI it will
look as if we just updated some State
and now we should see this item in our
database right let's look in the card
items collection and refresh this
and there's now one product in here with
a quantity of one and it also contains
the ID of the card where this is added
to us so 901 were the last digits and
it's the same idea that the card in the
card collection has
let's try adding the same item again and
see if we increase the quantity instead
of adding a new entry here so again we
click this button we see our loading
spinner
and let's refresh the database quantity
to a perfect
there should also now be a cookie set in
our browser with the same card idea so
this ends with 901 let's remember this
open the Chrome Dev tools with F12 and
we can see the cookies here in the
application tab
we can click here on cookies and on
localhost and there's the local card ID
that contains our current card ID and
this cookie will still be there when we
close the page and open it again and
this allows us to fetch our Anonymous
card even if we are not locked in so
this is really professional
this is also how big eCommerce website
actually do it they store the identifier
for the card in a cookie if we delete
this cookie
and add another item to the card then it
should create a new card right because
then the identifier for the card is
missing let's try this out let's delete
this code here just with the delete
button
and Let me refresh the page just to be
sure that the changes are applied and
click add to cart again
and then in our database we should see a
new card
and there it is and now we have a cookie
for this card ID instead now later I
will also explain to you how you can
delete cards automatically if they
haven't been updated for a while so that
we don't accumulate a lot of abandoned
cards in our database right but for now
let's ignore this now of course we could
also get rid of this loading State here
and let the database operation run in
the background but for something like a
shopping cart it's actually better to
have a loading spinner and then a
success message so that the user has a
confirmation that the item was
successfully added to the card because
if they click add to cart and then
navigate away and then the item wasn't
actually added to the cards for some
reason maybe it through an error maybe
there was some other problem then it's a
bad user experience if they don't
actually see the item in the card this
is why for an e-commerce app it's
actually better if there's a loading
spinner and a success message after the
operation has finished and this is also
how Amazon does it by the way let's also
add another item just to see that this
works as well a green bottle for example
again adds to cart edit
let's check the card items collection
and now we have one of these bottles in
here which would be this one this has
the product idea 588a which should also
be the idea
of the bottle here here
88a now at first I was worried about
race conditions when we click this
button multiple times in a row because
this also creates a new card when we
don't have one yet right and we want to
avoid accidentally creating multiple
cards because we hammered this button
multiple times in a row but when you try
this out you will actually notice that
these server actions are executed in
succession so even if we click the add
to cut button multiple times it will
first execute the first server action
and after this has finished it will
execute the second one which then
increments the quantity so there is no
raise condition at least this is how it
works in the moment again server actions
are in Alpha maybe they are changing
this behavior in the future but at least
for now this works exactly like it
should work let's actually try this out
as well let's delete our cards for a
moment we can just delete the whole
collection it will be recreated when we
create a new card and let's do the same
for the card items
gonna refresh the pitch and then I click
adds to cut fast two times in a row and
it should create only one card and then
increment the quantity of the existing
item to two so click click
two times
let's check our database
let's refresh this
zor there should be one card
and one card item with a quantity of two
so this works there is no race condition
and our app works fine okay cool later
we will add our card page where we can
change the quantity of the existing
items so then we will use another server
action but for now let's add enough bar
and the photo to our page so that we can
navigate between our different pages and
also show our cards and navigate to our
card later
okay before we set up our navbar I want
to make one more little change to our
schema file I want to add on delete
Cascade not only to the product but also
to the card
here in the card item model so again
comma
on delete colon Cascade with the
spelling because now when we delete a
card all the corresponding card items
will be deleted as well which I think
makes sense
all right and then we want to set up the
navbar that we put at the top of our
page
so that we can navigate between
different pages and we don't have to
type in the URL all the time we could
put enough bar into the components
folder but since we use it throughout
our whole app I like to put it directly
into the app folder here
in here we create a new folder called
navbar because we need multiple files in
there
and the first file we put in there is
navbar.tsx
of course we used the navbar provided by
a Tailwind UI you can find it in the
documentation there are different
variations you can find the code of it
but the one we are building here
combines different elements of this page
into one we use the shopping cart item
we use the search box so let's go back
into our project and Export a default
function
foreign
statement let's start building the UI of
the snuff bar
we start with a div
which we give a background color
with the class BG minus base minus 100.
before we continue let's save this and
then put it in the UI and we want the
snuff bar to be a visible on all pages
throughout our website so we put this in
the root layout
it's part of the HTML body but not part
of the main tag so above the main tag
we just render our navbar
and save it
let's see if we can already see
something in the UI not yet but we will
see something when we put content in
here
into this order diff we put another div
to which again we add some class names
so the first one is navbar which is
coming from this uium and this adds some
CSS attributes to a style dislike enough
bar then I want to give the snapbar the
same Max squid as the content of our
pages so that the elements of the navbar
don't stretch out throughout the whole
screen
so again we use max
w7xl that's also what the value that we
used here in our layout
for the main container we use the same
one here and this is why I wrap this
into this order div which applies the
background color of the navbar because I
want the background color to take up the
forward but the contents of the navbar
be constrained within this Max squared
field and to send that is on the screen
we add a margin Auto
then we make this nuff bar a flex column
the flex class is not necessary because
that's already included in the navbar
here
Flex color means the elements will be
aligned below each other but we only
want this to be the case on small
screens
so we add a break point here as M so on
small screens and higher the only value
below as m is XS so Flex coil will be
applied on XS screens so on very small
screens and on slightly larger screens
SM
and larger we want to set this to a flex
row so the elements are aligned
horizontally
and then we also add the gap of tool to
get some space between the items you
will see how this looks in a moment
after we added items to our enough bar
so the first item I want to put in the
navbar is the logo and the name of the
website which we wrap into another div
which we give the class name Flex 1
this adds this Flex one one zero percent
attribute which defines how these items
stretch over the available space of the
navbar
then in here we put a next link
so that we can click this item and
navigate to the front page so we set the
edge ref to just slash as a string to
get to the home page and inside this
link we put a next image that will
contain the logo of the website again
make sure the import is correct
we set the sr0
to the logo which I already included in
the starting project if you are not
using the starting project then you can
get the logo out of the project on
GitHub
twin srz should be an assets folder and
in here is the logo which I prepared
we have to import this here
so import the logo
from
at which is the root folder
in here is the assets folder
and in there is logo.png that's what we
want to use for the image source
and then we want to resize this to a 40
pixels times 40 pixels
entries that the alt text to A flomazon
logo
and then we close this
okay let's save this and see how this
looks so now we'll see our enough bar
with this logo in there
and I also want to put some text next to
this logo so still inside the link but
below the image
we write flomazon
but I want to style this properly else
we add some class names directly to the
link
we make this a button
or rather with status as a button it's
still a link
button ghost gives this a certain
styling that looks like this
looks pretty cool
we make all the text in here
larger with text XL
but the button automatically makes this
all uppercase we can revert this
with normal minus case and those are all
tailwind and Desi UI classes so now we
have this link here with the logo and
the name and when we click this we get
to the front page really cool okay below
this diff here so the flex one div
we put another div which will contain
the search field and the shopping cart
button but those will be aligned on the
right side whereas the logo is aligned
on the left side
so Flex 1 basically makes this part here
grow to all the available space
and it pushes these elements that we put
into this div to the right side
to this diff below we add the class
names
Flex none
and GAP 2 as well to get some spacing in
here
then in here we want to put the search
field for which we use a form
so we put a form in here
and we will use Observer action to
execute the search again into this form
we pass a div
with the class name form control and
again I'm getting these class names from
the Desi UI documentation
we close this div
and add an input field in here
which gets a safe closing tag as usual
we give this input the name search query
we set the placeholder to search
entry status like we did earlier on the
ads product page
we make this an input
with the input Borat styling
then I want this input field to take up
the full available width with W minus
four but the width will still be
constrained by the text that wrap this
input field and then I also want to set
a Min width of 200 pixels so that we
can't shrink the input fields to a very
tiny size where we can't use it anymore
and again we can use an arbitrary pixel
value like this
and when we saved us we see our input
field
and the snuff bar should now also be
responsive right so at a certain size
they should move below it and it works
but the input Fields doesn't get too
small at a certain size
it will just say no I don't want to
shrink any further and this happens at
100 pixels
and to execute the search we will use a
server action again and since this file
is not a client's component we can just
declare the server action directly in
here so we create an async function
cut search products
and the same as on the add product page
this takes
form data
and at the top of this function
we add the use server directive
then we want to get the search query out
of the form data
so we create a const the search query
and we have done this before
we call formdata.get
past the name of this input field which
is search query
and then recode to a string to turn this
into a string
and then below we check if search query
has a value
because we only want to execute a search
if there's actually something typed into
the input field then we call redirect
which we import from next navigation
make sure the import is correct
and we want to navigate to the search
page which we haven't set up yet but we
do this later
the URL will be a slash search
and we will pass the search query as a
URL query param so we add a question
mark
query equals
without the space and then we append the
search query value
the cool thing is that redirect also
works in server components and server
actions so we can execute this in here
and it doesn't require any JavaScript so
our search will work even if JavaScript
is disabled which is always nice to have
and to execute this when we submit our
form we do the same as we did earlier
we set the action
to the name of our server action search
products
now if you are experienced with HTML
then you might think we could also just
pass the URL that we want to navigate
tour to the form action instead of doing
this detour through the server action so
we could just put this part here
directly down here and remove the whole
server action altogether however this
would reload the page which is a very
jarring user experience with our
approach here we are not reloading the
page we have this very resolved
navigation we had enough bar and
everything stays in place and this just
looks and feels better than using the
normal URL action okay but the button
that shows the shopping cart will have
to be a client component because it
shows a pop-up menu and in order to show
and close this pop-up menu we need
JavaScript we don't get around this so
to not make this whole enough bar a
client component we put this into a
separate file
and we put this into the same love buff
holder here
let's color it a shopping cart button
and Export a component
with the same name as usual
now to this shopping cart button we will
pass the card itself so the shopping
cart that contains the data of the card
but we will fetch the card in our navbar
because this way we can fetch it server
side and we don't have to use a state or
anything like that we just pass it to
our client component here so at the top
we create an interface
the shopping cart button props
which will contain the card
which is off-type shopping cart that's
the type we created earlier with all the
card item and product information inside
account so we import those from the lib
folder
but this can also be neither because we
might not have created a card yet
okay and then we pass this card to the
component so here shopping cart button
props Andrea destructure the card out of
there
and then rear return some UI here
the order element is a div
which we give the class names
drop down
and drop down and
which again are these UI classes
for now let's save this and let's put
this shopping cart button into our
navbar
so first we have to fetch the shopping
cart right we can do this right here
because this is a server component
but we have to make this an async
function
then we can create a const card
and call await get card from our lib
folder
and now we have the card data and we can
pass it to our shopping cart button
we put a shopping cart button here right
below the form
opening angle bracket shopping cart
button and it expects the card
which we already fetched
then let's finish the shopping cart
button so back into this component and
most of the mark up here is coming from
the daisy UI documentation I just copied
this for the most part
in here we put a label
which we give the tab index 0. the top
index is necessary so that we can use
tab to navigate between items which is
necessary for accessibility
we style those
with BTN ghost
and BTN Circle which makes this round
yeah and the normal BTN class which is
the base button styling
we close this label tag
then we wrap this into another diff
to which we add the class name
indicator because this way we can have a
little batch on our cards button that
shows the current number of items in the
card
then in here we copy paste the same card
icon that we also use on the add to cart
button here so you can either copy paste
it from there or copy paste it from the
GitHub repository
when we save this we already see a
discount I can hear and to add some
number to this indicator here we go
below the SVG but still inside the stuff
and add another spin
which contains the number that we want
to put in there so we add an expression
with curly braces what do we want to put
in here we want to put the card size in
there
which is part of the shopping cart type
right so when we fetch a card we return
the size that we calculated earlier and
we want to display the size here
if this value is undefined because a
card doesn't exist yet then we want to
file back to a zero and when we left us
it's not styled properly yet
we have to add the class name
to this pen as well
the first one is batch
then batch s m for the size
and indicator minus item now when we
save this this is styled properly and
looks really cool doesn't it and this
always reflects the actual number of
items in our card
so when we are
add another item this will switch to a
three after this has finished loading
and number three
but we also want to show a drop down
menu when we click this item so we go
below this label here
and add another div
again the stiff gets this Tap index zero
value
and some class names to style this
the drop down will be stayed like a card
then we have drop down content and again
you can find instructions on how to
style these elements properly and the
devs the UI documentation
then we add cards compact which adds
some size styling
we need a margin top
we need a
width
which we set to a w minus 50 to 1 this
is just the width of this drop down menu
we need a background color with BG base
100 and we can add a drop shadow with
the shadow class
and one more class Z minus 30m this sets
the Z Index this takes care that this
drop down menu is not hidden behind
other elements so it's on the foreground
okay then we go inside this div and put
the contents of this drop down menu in
here
again we need another div
this is just unfortunately how HTML
works it's stiff within divs within divs
we style this with the card body class
and in here again I want to show the
size of the cards and also the subtotal
so the total dollar amount of our items
combined right now so inside the stiff
we put a spin
with the class names
text LG for the text size
and font bold
and this was there
number of items so we add an expression
and then items behind an index
expression we want to show the card size
again or file back to zero if we don't
have a card yet
and when we click our button here we
already see our drop down menu
now let's add a subtotal below as
another spin
which we give the class name text info
this changes the text color
and in here we write subtotal colon
and then we want to show the price which
we want to format remember for this we
have this format price function that we
created earlier
to this we want to pass card dot
subtotal which again we calculate when
we return the call again this might be
undefined in this case we want to file
back to zero again
okay save this
now we have this value in here as well
and it's actually the correct value so
this is correctly calculated one more
thing I also want to have a button in
here that brings us to the cart page
where we can then modify our account
right
So Below the subtotal span
we put another div
with the class name card actions
this is for buttons that we put into
this menu but we don't use a button we
use a next link again because we are
linking to another URL but this import
here is wrong we don't want to import it
from this dist folder we want to import
it
from
next
slash link
sometimes Auto Import doesn't work for
whatever reason but the curly braces are
wrong we have to remove them because
this is the default export
okay so this link will lead us to a
slash code again we haven't set up this
page yet but we will do so later
we'll style this link like a button with
BTN
a primary button with BTN primary
and to take up the full width we add BTN
block
and this button was there
viewer card
so now we have this button here that
brings us to the cut page which doesn't
exist yet
now since this page doesn't exist this
drop down menu closes when this page is
loaded for some reason but if we adjust
for a moment change this to a page that
does exist
and click this button again
then you can see that the drop down does
not close automatically we actually have
to handle this ourselves this is why we
need JavaScript unfortunately we can't
close this drop down menu without
JavaScript so make sure you set the href
back to slash card and then we add
another prop to the link
we want to set the on click Handler here
and we want to call close
drop down
and we put this function
here above the return statement
so we create a function
that we give the same name
and what we want to do is we want to
remove the focus from this button here
because this is what opens this drop
down menu
the way we do this is we get the
currently focused element like this
document DOT active element and you have
to do this with these days UI elements
you have to handle closing this drop
down menus yourself
then we have to cast this to an HTML
element
then we have to check if we found an
element we want to remove the focus
which we do with lm.blur
now when we save this we will get an
error
because on click requires this to be a
client component because onclick needs
JavaScript
so at the top we make this whole
shopping cart button a client component
saved us
and then it should work again just for
testing purposes I let this link us to
the home page but I set this back to the
card page in a moment
and now when we click this button we get
to the home page and the drop down menu
closest okay revert the spec
okay our enough bar is finished this is
really cool because now we see the
actual shopping cart data in here next
we want to set up the cards page where
this links us to but before we do this I
also want to add a simple photo to our
website just so that it looks more
complete so let's put the folder into
the app folder as well because it wraps
the whole website
photo.tsx and this time I'm just going
to copy paste this whole thing because
this is just some dummy markup I
actually copied this right from the Desi
UI documentation and I will put a link
to this file in the description below as
well so you can copy paste it from there
but again this is just some placeholder
and then reporters
into our root layout below the main
content
we render the photo here
safety and there's our beautiful
professional photo
that's also responsive by the way
this looks really a like right out of
amazon.com
okay there's one more bug I want to
mention right now again these server
actions are still in Alpha so they have
some bugs we have to wait until they are
fixed right now while a server action is
running we can actually not navigate to
another page over a link to try this out
for a moment I want to edit the layer to
our increment quantity action again I
will remove this in a moment
so here I await a new promise
and I'm trying to remember the syntax of
this you don't have to write this this
is just to show you something I just
want to create an artificiality layer
which we can do by a wedding
a timeout
so let's say we delay this for three
seconds just for testing purposes
now when I click this add to cart button
this will take over three seconds to
finish and while this is loading we can
actually not navigate to the front page
over this link
so this is loading and I click this link
and nothing happens
but the short work we only navigate to
the front page after this has finished
but this is a bug in server actions
right now so we just have to ignore this
for the moment there are discussions
about this on GitHub and I'm sure they
will fix this eventually but just that
you know that this bug exists so I want
to remove This Promise here again and
then we want to set up our cart page
all right let's set up our cut page
so we navigate to a slash cart when we
click our view cards button here
this means we need a folder in our app
folder with this name card
and in here we put a page.tsx
and then we export a default async
function
entry colored card page
then rear return the UI
re-wrap this whole page into a div
and in here we put the headline
that says shopping cart or your card or
whatever you want to put in here
entry style this
we set the text to a 3XL
we make it bold and add some margin
bottom
let's see how this looks view card
and there's the title we can also add
some metadata to this page
as usual by exporting a const metadata
static metadata here is enough we don't
need Dynamic metadata
and we set the title tool
your card
Dash
and this changes the title here in the
tab okay so the card is a server
component
meaning that we can fetch data in here
we want to fetch the card so that we can
show it on the screen right
get card from our lip folder
and then I want to list all the card
items as a vertical list here on this
page
with the price and the subtotal and the
image and everything so here we put an
expression
we take cut dot items which remember
contains also the product information
because we return our populated shopping
cart
so all the data is contained in this
items field
and then we want to map
each card item
into a UI element this UI element will
also contain the server action which
allows us to change the quantity of an
existing card item Zoo for organization
let's put this into a separate file and
we can co-locate this with the card page
here
let's call it card entry dot TSX
again this will be a client component
because we need JavaScript in here
and then we export a default function
with the same name
now to this component I want to pass a
Zinger card item
so one of these card item entries here
but I want the product information to be
inside it right this is already taken
care of by returning the shopping cart
here from the get card function but we
don't yet have a type that we can use
for this argument
so let's go back into the card file in
our lib folder again where we created
this card ref products type we also want
the type only for this part here for a
single item that contains the product
information
so let's add a second type below that we
create in the same way
we export a type
that we call a card item
with product
again we create it with Prisma
this time card item get payload not cart
get payload but card item then again
angle brackets
curly braces
and in here we put the query that is
required to populate a card item
which is include colon and to even get
out the completion
product colon draw so we want one card
item with the product information inside
it
okay we saved this we export this type
and then we can use it in our cart entry
here we create an interface for the
props as usual
card entry props
we need one card item which is of type
card item with product that we just
created
so this is one card item with the
quantity but also the populated product
then we add this prop down here
card entry props and 3D structure the
card item out of it and then we can show
this card item in the UI
so let's return
a div
in which we put another div
because below the card entry we also
want to put a divider which is just a
vertical line
So Below this inner diff we put another
div with a self-closing tag
that gets the class name divider which
again is coming from Daisy UI
and above in the stiff we put the actual
product information
so this div here at the top needs some
classes Flex
wrap which is required for
responsiveness so if there's not enough
room then the elements will
automatically move below each other
we want to Center the items
and give it a gap of three
then in here we put the product image as
usual as the next image
we set the sr0 to the image of the
product but we don't want to write card
item dot product dot all the time so we
can destructure this card item further
with colon curly braces and we care
about the product
and the quantity that's the data we need
in here and then down here in the image
source we can just write product dot
image URL
for the alt text we use the product name
again
we set the width and the highest to a
200 pixels
and we make the corners of this image
rounded with rounded LG
then we close this
before we continue let's save this and
add it to our map function here
so we map each card item
to one of these card entries
to which we have to pass
the card item of the snap function
and again since this is a list we also
have to add a keyer with a unique
identifier
which is we can use the ID or the
product idea shouldn't matter
and then we already see our product here
really cool
let's finish the cut entry layout and
add the remaining information
So Below the image we put another div
then we add a link here because the name
of the product will also be a link to
the product detail page
but Auto Import didn't work so we have
to import this manually
import link from next slash link
we set the href of this link
to a slash products
slash
and
product idea
because this brings us to the detail
page
and I want to set a class name to font
bold
and then this link will just contain the
product name
and the others
right below this link
I want to render the price of the
product
of a single item
so in a different rate price column
again we use our format price function
to which repairs product dot price
there it is that's the price for a
single green bottle
then below the stiff I also want to show
the total price so the price of one item
multiplied by the quantity so we add
another div here
with the class names Flex
item Center and GAP tool
and here we write total column
and again we want to format the price
but this time it's product dot Prius
multiply it by the quantity
it's not a product or quantity it's just
quantity because that's part of the card
item
so the total price is 15.96
which is also shown in our card drop
down
okay and I want to show the current
quantity between these two diffs here
but I also want to add a drop down
manual with which we can change the
quantity so we go below the price but
above the total and here we add another
div
but we are almost done
again we need some class names we need
some vertical margin my one
we make this a flex box with item Center
and a gap of tool
okay then this was a quantity column
and in here we put the select which
creates a drop down menu
in HTML then we need options for this
drop down manual I want to have the
numbers 1 to 99 in there so that we can
change the quantity for this we need an
array that contains the numbers 1 to 99
we create this array above the return
statement
we create a const quantity of options
this will be of type jsx element
but an array of jsx elements and we
initialize this with an empty array
yjsx element because we want to put
these option tags in there which are
HTML elements and we can put them into a
jsx array but we want to do so in a loop
that goes from 1 to 99 so we'll write 4
and create a normal for Loop let I
equals one that's the number we start
with
I less than or equal to 99
semicolon I plus plus this is just a
normal for Loop in JavaScript
and for each iteration we want to take
our quantity options
and push a newer element in here
as I already said we want to put such an
option tag in there
option tag contains a text with the
number so we just render iron here so
number 1 to 99 and then we also have to
set the value
of this option tag to the same number
and since this is an array we also have
to set it here for which again we use I
so this Loop here creates a list of
these option tags from number 1 to 99
that's all this does and now we can
render these options in our select tag
here so between the opening and the
closing tag we put in expression and we
want to render our quantity options here
and this is how it looks it's not styled
properly yet so let's do that next we
add class names to the
select tag
select which is a daisy UI class
select board
W foil
and a Max width
of 80 pixels
this way this input field stays
responsive and it can shrink but it will
not be bigger than 80 pixels because
that's enough and this is how it looks
we can also set the default value to the
current quantity because when we open
the page we don't want this to show one
if we have four green bottles in our
card right
so we can add the default value prop
entry simply set this to the quantity of
this current card item
so now when we save this and refresh the
page this shows four and now when we
change the quantity by selecting a
different one we want to execute a
server action that changes the quantity
of this item in the database
so we add the unchange prop here which
will be called whenever we'll select
something in this drop down
and here it gets past this ear argument
which is the drop down menu itself
so we add the function body here and
then we can get this value out of the
drop down menu and call our server
action and JavaScript is required to
execute on change this doesn't work in
the server component unfortunately this
is why we have to make this a client
component but as we already learned we
can still cause over actions in client
components so let's set up this new
Observer action next again we put it
into the same folder
again we colored actions.ts just like we
did for the increment product quantity
action just that this function here will
allow us to set an arbitrary quantity
and it will also revalidate a different
path it will revalidate the Scout page
to update it but besides of that we are
not doing anything new in here
so we make this file a server action
file
then we export in async function that we
call set product quantity
to which repairs the product idea
but also the quantity
in form of a number
so this will look very similar to the
other actions file we already have just
that here we only needed a product idea
because we always incremented by one but
we also need a card in this other file
and create one if it doesn't exist yet
so we copy this line here
paste it here we have to import these
functions
from the lip folder
again we want to check if this article
is already in the card so let's copy
this line here as well
put it here and then we want to do one
of three things if we set the quantity
to zero we want to remove this item from
the card completely if we set a positive
value and the article is already in the
cards then we want to update this item
with the new quantity and if the item is
not in the card then we want to create a
new one now with our current UI this
third case is not actually possible
because we can't set the quantity if the
item is not in the card already but
maybe you want to change the UI later so
we will take care of this possibility as
well so we check if quantity on that we
pass to this function
is equal to zero then we want to check
if the article is in the count only then
we can delete it right
then we call Prisma
dot cut item
dot delete
we want to delete the item where
just follow along
the idea
is equal to the article and card idea
that we just found we want to delete
this card item else if the quantity is
not zero but the positive number
then again we want to check if the
article is already in the card in this
case we call a weight Prisma Dot card
item dot update to change the quantity
we want to update the same item
as we used up here with the article and
card idea so we can reuse the same where
clause
but this time we also want to set the
data
we want to pass the new quantity and
again since the field and the variable
name are the same we can use the short
syntax here
okay and then we add an ads block to
this inner F here so if article and card
is not defined if we don't already have
this item in the card then we want to
await press my DOT card item dot create
and we set the data like this
this will look similar to how we created
the card item here
so we can actually copy paste this over
the data is the card idea the product
idea but we don't want to set the
quantity to one we want to set it to the
quantity value that we pass to this
function
and at the end of our Z product quantity
function out of this outer if block here
we wanna revalidate the page again right
with revalidate path this time we want
to revalidate slash card which again
refreshes the page and fetches the
latest data
and now we want to cut the server action
in our card entry file but remember this
is a client component and because of
this one bug we can't import a server
action directly in the client component
because this will not work with next off
later so again we have to import the
server action in the page which is a
server component and then pass it to the
card entry but we haven't added the
arguments to the card entry yet so over
into the card entry again
into the card entry props here we expect
the Z product quantity tier that's a
difficult word function which is this
over action
and again it gets the same signature as
the job actually just set up
it takes the product ID and form of a
string
and the quantity and form of a number
oops and it returns a promise of type
White
and then we are
edit down here as well
but again we import the server action in
our page and pass it to the component so
let's go into the card entry
tag here
pass set product quantity for which we
import our newer server action
okay we save this go back into the card
entry down to our unchanged function
here
first of all we want to get the
selection out of this field here
which we can do the following way we
create a variable I'm gonna call it
newer quantity
equals
pulse int
because this contains a string and we
want to pass this into a number
and the value is contained in this ear
value that we get here
dot current Target dot value
and there's the selection of this drop
down field
and then we want to execute our server
action and pass this quantity to it
remember we need a transition to execute
the server action in a client component
to get the appropriate loading and error
handling so we scroll to the top of the
card entry file again
here inside the function at the top
again we create this cons is pending
comma start transition
the same one we used in our adds to cut
button
and we assign this to a US transition
back down into it the on change Handler
we have this new quantity here
now we start the transition
to which we pass this async Arrow
function again
and in here we can call and await set
product quantity which is the server
action
to which we pass the idea of the product
comma and the newer quantity that we
just selected
and again to have some feedback I want
to show a loading spinner while the
server action is running
we put it here below the total price we
don't need a success tax this time
because we see the up-to-date value in
the drop down so a loading state is
enough
we add an expression here
check if is pending is true
and if this is true we want to render a
span again that contains the loading
spinner
so spend with the class names
loading
loading spinner and loading SM for the
size
okay and when receive this this should
not work let me select the different
quantity three it loads
and it changed the quantity also up here
in the navbar and also the total price
this all gets refreshed because we call
revalidate perfume which revalidates
this whole page and fetches the latest
data but I put this loading spinner in
the wrong place I actually want to have
it inside the stiff here
so that it's shown right next to the
total price so now it looks like this
just one more addition I also won't have
an option for zero right so that we can
remove an item we put this above the
quantity options I don't make it part of
the loop because the text will be a bit
different so we add another option here
and the text will not only contain the
number zero but also remove
in parentheses this is also how Amazon
does it
and the value will be zero
and remember in our server action zero
means that the item will be completely
deleted from the card
so let's try this out let's refresh this
so we see the correct data again now we
have zero remove
which removes this item from the card
completely
by then it also makes sense to have some
text here when our card is emptier right
so it doesn't just look like this and
the user might be confused so let's go
into the cut page once again
and go below the map function here
inside the div
we add another expression
we want to check if exclamation mark
cart dot items dot length which means
that it's either undefined or zero
if this is the case we want to render a
text so we can use a paragraph tag for
this or a div doesn't really matter
because it's unstyled and Tailwind
anyway
your card is emptier
there's the text and then I also want to
put the total price of all card items at
the bottom and the checkout button So
Below this expression
we put another div
in here we put another paragraph tag
to which we add the class name mb3 for
our margin
and font bold
this will contain the total price just
like we show in the navbar
so this is total colon
curly braces
format price
and to this repairs card dot subtotal
and again if this is undefined because
we don't have a card yet we file back to
zero
that's the total value at zero right now
and Below we put the checkout button
which will start with BTN
and BTN primary
and this was a checkout
again we don't add functionality to this
checkout button here if you want stripe
integration then let me know in the
comments below it then I will make a
separate tutorial about stripe I also
want to Center these items so we add a
class name to this div
we make this a flex box and a flex
column
and what I want to do is on very small
screens I want the button and the total
amount will be on the right side because
that's usually easier to click when you
are on your phone and you want to use
your thumb and on larger screens I want
to align this in the middle also I just
think it looks cool for responsiveness
so again we can use breakpoints for this
we use items and
to align the items on the right side
and then on small screens and larger
we use items Center instead
one more thing I also want to change the
size of the checkout button but only on
this SM breakpoint
so here we add SM colon and then I want
to set the width of this button to a
hard-coded 200 pixels
which makes it a bit wider so now the
button and the total amount are centered
like this
but on very small screens it moves to
the right side and the button gets a bit
smaller I think this just looks better
and it's great for usability I think
okay let's format this and just try it
out one more time with different card
items to make sure this works so some
headphones add to cart
again this glitch where the font flashes
for a moment will not be in production
this only happens in development so
maybe let's add two cameras
and maybe one boss to wear
go to the card we see our subtotal here
we also see it here at the bottom and we
see the correct quantities right
which we can also change it updates all
these values and again if we change the
price for example of a product in the
database and the user comes back to
their cart then these changes will be
reflected in the UI the way we fetch our
data they will always see the latest
price and the latest product information
so this works really cool and
professionally in my opinion okay cool
then the next step is to add user
authentication into our website so that
the user can log in and can also connect
the shopping cart to their account it's
a very exciting stuff you don't want to
miss this
to handle authentication we'll be used
next off which is an authentication
Library specifically for next.js it
works with different authentication
strategies we have a lot of different
providers available in our app here we
will only implement the Google provider
to have Google log in but you can easily
add additional login providers later if
you want and it also has different
database adapters that we can use there
is an adapter for Prisma and mongodbir
which makes it very easy to store user
information and also session data in our
mongodb database using Prisma here you
can see that we have some stuff that we
have to add to the Prisma schema but I
will show you exactly how this works in
a moment to implement Google
authentication we need a project in the
Google Cloud console so you can either
go to a
console.cloud.google.com or click on the
link in the video description and then
we want to set up a project here
this is free to use if you already have
a Google account then you should also be
logged in automatically
and here we can create a new project
I'm going to call it next Js
e-commerce
and then we click on create
this takes a moment to create this new
project and then when this is done we
click on select project which selects
this project up here on the drop down
okay and then in the sites bar we want
to go to a credentials which is part of
apis and services here we have
credentials but we have to go to the O
of content screen first because we have
to set this up first
okay let's go through these steps user
type external because we want to make
this website available to all kinds of
users at least in theory
create we have to give this app a name
um
next JS e-commerce
user support email for this we can
select the email address of this Google
account we don't have to upload a logo I
think we can leave this stuff here empty
for now as well
develop a contact information again I'm
going to use the same address here
coding and flow recording at gmail.com
and then we click on Save and continue
here we can select Scopes we only need
the user profile info and the email
address this doesn't require access to
any specific Google servers and we also
don't need any special permissions to
get these values we click here on update
we don't need any sensitive or
restricted Scopes so we click on Save
and continue
we can set up test users while this app
is not in production that are allowed to
log in again I'm going to use the
recording email address
and maybe at the second one here
infrared coding and floorpongs.com
add
save and continue
okay now we can confirm this external we
have a project name email address and so
on Scopes test users yeah then we click
back to dashboard
so this app is now in testing mode if
you ever want to publish your website
then you also have to publish this
Google app to make it available in
production but for testing purposes this
is now working and then we want to set
up credentials so we click on credential
C under sidebar and then on create
credentials and we need an oauth client
idea
the application type is a web
application
name maybe let's call this next JS app
or whatever
then for authorized redirect Uris we add
the URL to localhost 3000 with HTTP
colon in front of it that's not https or
localhost it's just HTTP and then we
need this executive path here because
this is what next of expects this is
where Google will redirect us to after
the login was successful and this is
where next off reads the data out of the
Google profile and gives it to us
basically so this has to point to slash
API slash off slash callback slash
Google
we add this here and of course later in
production you have to add a second
redirect URL with the actual deployment
domain
okay we click on create
and then we get the client ID and the
client secret and we want to put both of
them into our end file in our project
where we already have our database
credentials
so here we are at the Google client idea
and then we are copy paste this value
over here
from your Google Cloud console
and a Google client secret which was the
second string that we got
we paste it here as well
then we can close the Google Cloud
console because we shouldn't need this
anymore now our client is set up and we
can use this to look in via Google
there are two more environmental
variables that we need for next off the
first one is next of underscore URL
which contains the base URL of our
website and you have to give this
variable this exact name with the same
spelling because next off expects a
variable with this name
so we set this to the base URL again
HTTP colon slash slash localhost colon
3000.
and then we also need the next of
underscore Secret
this is just a random string so you can
type any letters in here that you want
that is used to encrypt the session
cookie later this is just needed for
security and this is basically a
password you can add any string you want
here this next off secret is only
required in production later we will
deploy this website and then we will get
an error if we don't have this value set
okay let's save this and then the way
next off works is that we have to set up
a route Handler so an API endpoint and
next.js under a very specific URL and
every authentication request will then
go to this URL and next off will handle
this this is also where we pointed the
redirect URL in the Google Cloud console
to earlier so we go in the sites bar
here in the app folder we create a new
folder called API and we have to put
this folder in here with this exact name
because next off expects a very specific
route in here we put another folder
called off
then another folder
called scrap records dot dot dot
next off as one word
and in here finally we put the route
Handler
which we call road.ts route handlers are
how you set up API endpoints so server
endpoints in the next js13 app when you
use the app order and this part here
with the dot dot dot is a so-called
catch R segment this allows next off to
handle different routes under this
endpoint and not just a single one okay
and in this route dot TS file
we export const
of options
and this time the name is arbitrary
again so this doesn't have to be called
off options
and this will be of type next of options
which is an import from next off
and this will just contain the next of
configuration the reason I put this
configuration into a separate variable
and Export it from this file is because
we also need this object later in other
places in our app okay and we set the
adapter to Prisma adapter
this is available in next off by default
and this allows us to save user
information and session data in our
mongodb database using Prisma so this
works together really well and to the
Prisma adapter we pass our Prisma client
now this complains because there's a
typescript problem that requires us to
also cast this
to an adapter to a next off adapter so
that this error message disappears
sometimes there are some typescript
shenanigans that you have to work around
comma
and then reset providers
to an array here you can add multiple
providers but again in this video we
only add Google login
so here we pass a Google provider okay
autocomplete doesn't work
the import is
import Google Provider from
next off
slash providers
slash Google there it is
now we can use the Google provider down
here
and configure it with curly braces
this expects the client ID and the
client secret that we already have right
in our environment variables
so we can get them with process.enth
Dot
we need the same name
Google client idea
and client secret is
process.nf Dot
Google client Secret
now this complaints we will get rid of
this error in a moment but first let's
finish this file here so we have our off
options
and Below we create a constantly again
this is explained in the next of
documentation
here we call this next of function to
which we pass the off options and this
sets up next off with this configuration
here with our Prisma adapter and the
Google provider
and then we have to export it the
following way export curly braces
Handler ascat
comma
Handler as post
this weird syntax is necessary because
right now next off is the configured to
work with the old Pages directory and
next.js and not with the app directory
that we are using and this is why we
have to write the special syntax to make
this work with route handlers but this
is totally valid this is also described
in the documentation now this your
complaints because an environment
variable can always be undefined because
we might have forgot to reset it but the
Google provider expects defined values
for client ID and client secret now one
simple way to get around us would be to
just add the non-net assertion operator
here with exclamation marks but this is
actually not great because if we
actually forget to set these environment
variables then we will continue with
undefined values and this will just
misbehave it's better to actually check
if all our environment variables are set
and throw an error if this is not the
case this is why we also installed the
zot Library here we can use this to
validate the values for example our
environment variables this is a very
useful thing to do in your next JS
projects so that you can always work
with the find Environment variables
and I will show you how you can set this
up we want to go into our lib folder
again
and put another file in here which we
just call nf.ts
here we want to import sort
of from sort
then we create a validation schema for
our environment variables const I'm
going to call it INF schema
and then we can create such a sort
object
in the sort object we can pass
validation rules
and then here we want to add the same
variables that we also have in our
normal.n file
so we want to copy all these five names
and paste them in here and now we can
add validation words to all of them
and they all have the same rules they
are strings that are not emptier so
behind each of them we write a colon and
by the way you can duplicate the cursor
by pressing somewhere then you hold Ctrl
alt I guess on Mac this is command alt
I'm not sure and then you press the down
arrow and then we press the end button
on the keyboard to get to the end of the
line but you can also handle each line
manually if you want okay as one each of
them will be a sort dot string
which is a function
and then we also call non-emptier
to guarantee that this trend contains
something and the comma at the end of
each line
now below
we export the cons that we call enf
and we assign this to end schema dot
pulse this way we can pass a value to
the schema and validate it
and what do we want to pass well we want
to pass all our environment variables to
it
because we expect our environment
variables to adhere to this exact schema
we should have these five keys that are
non-empty strings
and now if one of them is missing or
emptier then search will throw an arrow
with a readable error message instead of
just giving us an undefined value
and now we go back into our route file
and instead of process.enth we just use
nth entry importers from our lib folder
the file we just set up and now since we
validated this with sort this is
guaranteed to be a string
if it's missing we will get an error
okay next we go into our root layout and
we have to wrap our whole layout into a
session provider what this does is it
makes the session so our locked in user
basically available to our components
throughout our app this is actually only
necessary to get a session in client
components because in server components
it works differently entry would not
need this in our app because we fetch
all our session data server side but
it's still good to add this because if
you need a session client-side then you
need this wrapper okay autocomplete
doesn't work so we have to import this
manually
import
destructure
from next off
slash react
and in here we can find this session
provider
entry wanna wrap our navbar our main tag
and the photo
into the session provider again to make
the session available to all our pages
but when we save and refresh this I
think we should get an error yeah there
it is because this uses react context
internally and this requires a client
component but the root layout is a
server component now we could make the
whole root layout a client component to
fix this but there's actually a better
way to fix this
basically what we want we want the
session provider to have to use client
directive at the top just like our own
client components the problem is many of
these libraries haven't added this yet
because react server components are
still newer and we can't go into the
source code of the session provider and
add use clients there ourselves right
but there is an easy workaround for this
we just have to export these third-party
components that we want to turn into
client components from our own client
file
so we go into our app folder and put a
new file here which we give the same
name
session provider dot TSX
we make this file a client component
and then we simply re-export the session
provider
from next off
so we add the same package here but this
time we write export instead of import
so again next off slash react
and here we have the session provider
but we want to make this the default
export
which we can do with this syntax
then we go back into our root layout and
we want to change the impulse statement
here we don't want to import it from
next off anymore
but our own file so dot to get into the
parent folder slash a session provider
and since this is Now the default export
we can delete this Cali braces
and now the should work because we
turned the session provider into a
client component we can still use all
the features of it no problem but now we
can also use it inside a server
component next we have to add some newer
models to our Prisma schema this is
described in the next of documentation
they have instructions for the different
adapters and we are using the Prisma
adapter
we have to add these models here the
account and user version and so on and
then we also have to make some
modifications to make this work with
mongodb but I already prepared all of
this let's go back into our project and
into the
schema.prisma file
and at the bottom below the card item
model we have to copy paste a bunch of
new models I will put a link to this
schema file into the video description
below so you can copy paste this from
there
so this includes the user account this
contains the username email address and
the image which we get from Google when
the user signs in then the Google
account information is stored as well in
a separate collection there is some
stuff in here that we don't actually
need but we might need this in the
future if we change our authentication
strategy so it's good to add all of this
then we also store a session in the
database when the user is logged in
sessions are alternative to JWT
authentication when you connect next off
to a database using one of these
adapters the Prisma adapter in our case
then authentication will automatically
be handled with sessions session means
that when a user logs in the association
entry created in our database that
contains the user ID and an expiration
date sessions are easier to use
correctly than Jade label your tears
because you can invalidate sessions
simply by deleting them from the
database so if the user changes their
password for example a and you want to
lock them out everywhere else then you
can just delete their sessions whereas
this is not possible with jwts by
default because they are self-contained
in order to implement jwts properly you
have to implement the complex refresh
token mechanism this is also possible
it's also possible with next auth but
sessions are much easier to use
correctly but again next off handles
these sessions automatically for us we
don't have to create them next off
dusters and then we also have this
verification token model as far as I
know it these are only used if you
implement login with an email link which
we are not using here but again it's
still good to add all of these models at
once in case you want to add additional
authentication strategies okay and then
we also want to be able to connect a
shopping cart to a user right so that we
don't only have Anonymous shopping carts
where we store the card ID in a Kobe
instead we can also store a user ID on a
card and this way know which user this
belongs to the zoo on the card model and
I put this above the timestamps
we add a user idea
which will be of type string this will
contain an object idea but we make this
value optional with a question mark
after string because Anonymous shopping
carts don't have a user ID right
and then we also need this object ID
annotation because this contains a
mongodb object ID
then we also add the relation below like
we also did for the product and the
cards on the card item
we call this one just user
it will be of type user which is our
user model that we just copy pasted
it's optional again because it's
connected to the user ID which is also
optional because a card could not belong
to a user account yeah and then we add
the same line as here basically
just that we change this to a user idea
we press the formatting shortcut to
align this properly and the counterpart
to this user field here
is on the user model discard array I
think if we delete this and press the
formatting shortcut again yeah it gets
added back automatically because this
belongs
to this user relation with that up here
this relation basically allows us to do
two things first of all when we delete a
user we can automatically delete their
accounts and for an existing user we can
fetch all their cards if we allow
multiple cards per user but again this
whole file is linked in the video
description below so we can copy paste
it from there it's so good to understand
what is going on here okay and then we
want to push these changes to our
database to create these new collections
so we open the terminal stop the
execution
and run npx Prisma DB push again
as you can see it created and configured
a bunch of new collections which we
should Now find
in our Atlas backend
sessions verification tokens users and
so on they are empty right now and then
we want to re-generate our Prisma client
to have these new methods available I
think this actually happens
automatically when you run DB push but
just to be sure
we run npx Prisma generate again
which generates this new updated Prisma
client
and then real npm run Dev again
okay and then I want to put a newer
button into our enough bar that shows
the profile picture of the user when
they are logged in and also contains a
drop down menu to log out this button
needs to be a client component because
we need to handle button clicks there
and the same as we did for the shopping
cart button let's put it into its own
file so that we can keep the navbar
itself as a server component so we have
the shopping cart button we create a new
file
which we call user menu button
so then we export a default function
user menu button
and here we are
return a div
we also add props
interface user menu button props
we want to show the currently locked in
user in this user button and we can get
the user out of the session and we get
the session from next off so we add
session colon as a prop
entry set the type to session from next
off this one here so this is the import
statement but the user might not be
logged in so we add a vertical bar and
now so that we can also pass null for
the session
now we could also fetch the session
directly in here with this us session
Hook from next off this fetches decision
client-side but I want to fetch the
session server side in our navbar which
is a server component because this way
decision data is available as soon as
our Pages opened there is no short
moment when the user is not
authenticated instead the user is logged
in right array and this is also how we
set up our shopping cart right I want
there to be a no loading time instead I
want all the data to be there as soon as
the page is opened again because I think
this feels more professional and this is
also how it works on websites like
Amazon this is why we don't get the
session directly in here because this
has to be a client component
we also add the use client directive at
the top because we later need to handle
on click events here and this is only
possible in a client component then we
destructure our props as usual here in
the function
user menu props and in here is our
session
and then
the first line of this function
we want to get the user object out of
the session which we can do with session
dot user and it adds the save call
Operator because the session can be null
okay and then we finish the layout
itself we add some class names to the
outer diff
again we use drop down and drop down end
which we also used before for the
shopping cart button
again we put a label with this tab index
0 in here
and we add some class names to the label
as well
BTN BTN ghost and BTN Circle again the
same classes we used on the shopping
cart button
okay and then in this button I want to
show something different depending if
the user is logged in or not so we add
an expression that checks if the user is
defined
we use the ternary operator with a
question mark
if the user is defined I want to render
the user image in the next image
before we set up this image let's also
add the second part of the ternary
operator colon if the user is not
defined I want to render yeah three
little dotsier which indicate that this
is a drop down menu
for this we use an SVG again and again I
will link this file in the video
description so you can copy paste it
from there we can't get around this
because yeah we can't type this out by
hand we can only copy paste these svgs
let's press the formatting shortcut so
this gets aligned properly and again
prettier automatically adds these
parentheses
which are very useful
for the source of the image we want to
pass
user.image and again we get this from
Google when we log in this will
automatically be filled with the image
of the Google account of the user but
user can be undefined right so we have
to add a safe cut operator here
and we want to use something else as a
fallback for this I prepared this
profile pic placeholder image
which is in the assets foil this one
here
I want to import this and use this as a
fileback
so at the top we import profile pic
placeholder
from at slash assets slash Prof epic
placeholder PNG
and then we can use it as the file back
here
profile pic placeholder in case the user
or the image is undefined
we set the alt text to just profile
picture I think this is enough
we set the width and height both to 40
pixels
and then we also want to style this with
W10
which sets the width of the image but in
CSS to the same 40 pixels as we also
loaded because again the final
dimensions are dictated by CSS not by
these values we are using here at least
when we use this component and then we
want to make this a circle
which we can do with rounded foil this
adds the Border radius to over 9000 and
this creates a round image
okay so if the user is logged in we see
their profile picture if they are not
logged in we see this SVG which is three
little dots basically you will see this
in a moment
and outside of this label but still
inside the stiff inside the drop down
menu we add the drop down menu items so
in here we put a ul and unordered list
this is just a normal HTML tag
and to the opening tag of UL we add this
tab index 0 again again this is
necessary for accessibility so that we
can use tab to navigate between our
menus
and again this needs a class name
which are drop down content
manual
rounded box and again I got all of them
from this URL
menu minus SM
then we need this c Index again to make
sure that this menu is in the foreground
we add the match on top with mt3
we set the width to a w52
let me make this bigger we set the
background color with BG base 100
then we need some padding and lastly we
also want to give this a shadow not SM
but just normal shadow
and into the UL we put list items for
the Zinger buttons in our drop down menu
you can put multiple once in there we
actually only need one but the contents
of this item are different depending if
we are locked in or locked out if we are
logged in we wanna show the log out
button and if we are logged out we want
to show the login button right
so we add an expression here again with
a ternary operator
if we have a user then we want to render
a button
that says
sign out
if the user is not logged in then we
want to render a button that says
sign in
and then we give both of these buttons
on click handlers this is why we had to
make this a client component because we
can only use on click with JavaScript
and in here we pass an error function
like this
and in order to sign out we can call
this sign out function which is coming
from next off so we add this import here
entry code this function
we can also configure this between curly
braces and we can zero when we are
locked out we want to be redirected back
to the front page so we can set the
Callback URL to the home page
and to sign in we also passing on click
Handler with an anonymous function
which simply calls sign in
now instead of these functions we could
also use links because they are specific
URLs where we can navigate the user tool
so they also get to the next of login
screen the benefit of using design and
function rather than design in url
endpoint is that this automatically
redirects us to the previous page after
signing in so if we are on a product
page and we sign in we get redirected to
the product page and not to the home
page and the same is the case for sign
out by default but here we have changed
this Behavior by setting the Callback
URL explicitly you can remove this if
you want okay let's format and save this
and now we only have to add this user
menu button to our love bar and then log
in short work
I just realized one little mistake I
want this not to be a BG Bluer but BG
base 100 this is the correct value
okay then we open the NAFTA TSX file and
we want to put the user menu button
right next to the shopping cart button
and it's already styled correctly
but this expects the session as input
right which we want to fetch here in our
enough bar because again the navbar is a
server component and this way we can
fetch the session before the page is
actually opened so here at the top we
create a const session
we cut a weight get a server session
this is a function from next off that we
can use in server components to get the
session of the logged in user from the
database
now to this get server session we also
have to pass the off options where is
this coming from those are the next half
options that we set up in our route
Handler earlier this is why we export
them here because we have to pass them
to get server session otherwise this
will not work
okay so this way we get the session of
the currently locked in user from the
database and the way this works is that
next offsets an encrypted cookie in the
browser of the user to identify the
correct session in the database and know
if they are locked in or not and then we
simply pass the session
to our user menu button and save this
and now on our website when we refresh
the page we should see our user menu
button and the other days we are
currently not logged in so we see these
three little dots which are the SVG we
pasted and now let's try this out let's
log in
by clicking the sign and by default we
get to this screen here you can
customize this screen or replace it for
a completely different one this is
explained in the next of documentation
but for our project here this is fine
sign in with Google
and then I want to sign in with one of
my accounts
then we get redirected back to the page
and this error happens because we are
trying to load the profile picture from
googleusercontent.com but this will only
work if we allow this address in our
next config file so we go into our
project
open nextconfig.js
and here we already allow images from
unsplash.com right so here we want to
add a second entry
this will comma another pair of curly
braces
and we set the host name to this one
here
let's actually copy this
put it here
maybe the address is different for you
copy whatever you see here as the host
name
this entry restart the development
server with npm rundev but we should
still be locked in I think
so let's refresh the page
and there we are and this is the profile
picture of my Google account which you
can also see up here
and this user information is now stored
in the database
let's refresh this
here we have the user florianwalter with
the image from Google and in the
accounts collection there's all the
information about this Google account
now right now a user account doesn't
have their own shopping cart yet we
still have our Anonymous shopping cart
that's connected to the kogi we will set
up user shopping carts in the next
section and then we will also merge the
anonymous card with the user's card when
we log in let's check if logout works as
well so I click on sign out
entry are locked out
let's log in again sign in with Google
recording account
and we are logged in
really cool and again since we fetched
the user server side and our enough bar
when we refresh the page the user is
there immediately there is no glitch in
the UI there is no loading State we have
the user and the shopping cart both
available as soon as the page is opened
but to see that we are actually
authenticated let's add some protection
to our ads product page we make it so
that not anyone can open this page
instead we have to be logged in to add a
product of course in a real app you
probably want to make this available
only for an administ trailer but here we
will just add simple authentication
protection so the ads product page is a
server component right this means we can
fetch our session
with get server session again
to which again we have to pass the off
options
we also have to make this an async
function
and then we can simply check if
possession is undefined on Nile
then we want to redirect the user
and we already have this import here
from next navigation
tool
design in endpoint which we find under
slash API
slash off
slash design in
and as I explained earlier by default
when we use the URL instead of design in
function this doesn't redirect us to the
page where we were previously at it
redirects us to the front page instead
but we can configure this manually and
by adding the Callback URL param so
question mark
URL in camera case spelling like this
and then we want to redirect tool
slash at minus product so that we get
back to this ad product page
so let's try this out while we are
logged in we should be able to access
the add product page
but if we logged out we should be
redirected to the login page when we try
to access the Edge product page we get
to the login page
we log in and then we should be
redirected to the ads product page so
this works it also makes sense to add a
protection to the server action itself
in case we are trying to call this while
we are not logged in so here at the top
after us server we fetch the session
here as well
with a weight get server sessions to
which again we pass the off options now
we basically want to do the exact same
thing as here
if the session is now we want to
redirect the user but this happens when
we click the add product button while we
are not logged in okay before we go on
let's also check if our nth validation
here works so when I remove an
environment variable from the dot nth
file
for example the Google client idea
and then restart the development server
we should see an error message because
this will not be able to fetch the user
information
let's try this out
we refresh the page
the session is now and we get the sort
error which is caused because it's
trying to pass the nth schema with the
process.n files but since the Google
client ID is missing this throws an
error with a very readable error message
we immediately see what is wrong and we
don't accidentally continue with an
undefined value so this works as well
let's add the Google client ID back
restart the development server
and open our page again
okay now let's go into our cut TS file
in the lip folder again
and adapt our get card and create card
functions to our newer user
authentication let's start with create
cards right now we only create an
anonymous card that's not connected to a
specific user right
so in here let's fetch the session
concession equals a weight get server
session we can use get server session
here because we only calculate card from
server components
again we have to pass the off options
here
and then instead of creating the new
cards variable here we delete the const
and instead above recreator let a new
card
which is of type card that's the type
coming from the Prisma client
this is the same type we get back when
we call cards.create it's an unpopulated
card
okay then below we want to check if we
are logged in
so we check if session has a value
if it doesn't have a value then we want
to create our Anonymous card as before
so we paste in this part
and we also paste in
the code that creates the cookie
if we are locked in we also want to
create a new card but this one will be
tied to a user account so again a way to
Prisma Dot card dot create
then we pass data
and here we want to set the user idea
to a session
dot user
dot idea now the ID is by default not
content in the user object because next
off doesn't return it to us by default
we have to add this ourselves so let's
just write ID here for now this gives us
an error
we go into our route Handler so this
next of Route file we created earlier
and here we can change what data we want
to return in the user object
by adding a callback so under providers
we add this callbacks field
to which repairs curly braces
and in here we get Auto completion
we can use this session callback which
will be triggered whenever we return a
session from the database and here we
can hook into this process and modify
what data we get back we can also
destructure this paramsion so we remove
params and add curly braces instead and
in here we want to have the session
and the user object
and then we can there we want to set a
session
Dot user.id
to the idea that's contained in this
user object this way we take the ID of
the user in our database and add it to
the version so that we can access it
here
but typescript doesn't recognize that
there is an ID field on this session
user in JavaScript this will just work
but in typescript we also have to
configure this type here before we do
this let's finish this function
at the entry have to return the session
so that we can use it in our app
to fix this problem here we have to
extend this user type
for this we go into our folder
and outside of srz this time
so right here with all these
configuration files we want to create a
new folder
which we call adds types
this is a naming convention for type
files in here we put a new file that we
call next of
dot d dot TS
D dot TS files are typescript
declaration files and here we can make
changes to existing types and in here we
write
declare module
and as a string we write next off
because this is the library where we
want to make changes to a type
curly braces and we want to change
the session interface
this is what we want to change
this session object which contains the
user but the user doesn't have an idea
so in interface Obsession we write user
column
again a pair of curly braces and in here
we put the ID value that we want to add
to this user it's of type string
but we also want to have all the other
values that are on the user available by
default because when we write it this
way now the user only has an idea
to also add these other values back to
the user we go after the closing curly
brace here write an Amazon sign to
create an intersection type and then we
use
default session from next off
to which we add scrap records and then
here we write user as a string
so this way we extend this next off user
and add this idea field to it
let's reformat this and save it
and now our arrows here disappeared and
now in our
card file in the lip folder we also
don't have an error anymore now the idea
of the user is added
to the user in the session when we
return a session okay so now when we
calculate cards it checks if the user is
logged in if yes it creates a card
connected to this user if not it creates
an anonymous card like before now let's
scroll up to create cards and do the
same here as well
in the first line we want to retrieve
the session
then we want to create a variable for
this card here so we remove the const
here
instead we create a lead card
by this card we've had here is populated
with the product information right with
these include options we used here
so the return type of this is card with
products the type that we created
earlier
so let card cartridge products or null
if we don't have a card yet and we
initialize this with Naya
then again we check
if we have a session
or not if we don't have a session we
want to do the same as before we want to
fetch the cook here with the local card
idea
and fetch this Anonymous card
if we have a session we want to fetch
the card of this user so cart equates a
weight
Prisma dot cart
dot find first this time it's not find
unique because a user can have multiple
cards but here we only support one card
so we use find First
and in curly braces we add the photos
we want to fetch the card well
the user idea in the card
that's part of the schema
that we modified earlier so a cardinal
has a user ID which is optional
we want to find the card where the user
idea
is the idea of the currently locked in
user
comma and of course we want to include
the same populated card item data
and the rest stays the same right so
let's try this out when I refresh the
page we should see an empty card because
there is no card connected to this user
account yet right
so I have to start the development
server again
refresh the page
and the card is emptier
now we should be able to add an item to
the card
it creates a card for this particular
user
when we log out we should see the
anonymous card again
so that's the anonymous card
and when we log in we should see this
user's card again
and we should also see two cards in our
database
there they are one has a user ID and the
other doesn't Okay cool so this is
working now let's implement the logic
that merges the anonymous card with the
user's card when we log in this is also
how it works on Amazon so you are logged
out you add some items to your cart and
then you log into your account these
items are moved into your user card for
this let's create a new function here in
our lib folder and our card TS file
let's put it at the bottom
export async function
and I'm gonna call it merge
Anonymous card
into a user card it's a very long name
but it's very descriptive
and to this function we pass the ideal
of the user that we want to merge the
card into
and here we have to write a little bit
of logic the first step is we want to
fetch the local card F1 access
first we need a cookie
just like in get cards let's copy this
line
put it here
okay and we also want to get the local
card from the database right so let's
copy this part here as well
where we assign logo card
we create a const card where we assign
this tool
and we need to populate the items
because we want to merge these items
together so we need to know which items
are in the cart but we don't need the
product information because this is not
necessary to merge these cards
so what we do is we remove this part
here include product rule and just write
true instead this populates the items
field but it doesn't populate the card
items with the product information
instead they will only contain the
quantity and the product ID let's also
rename this variable to local card and
if there is no local card then there's
nothing to merge right
So Below we check if exclamation mark
local card we just run a return
if there is a local card then next we
need the users card
so we create a const user card
equals await Prisma
Dot card
dot finder first again
because a user can have multiple cards
so this doesn't work with find unique
well
the user IDs match
with the user ID value we passed to this
function
and again we want to include
the card items in here but we don't need
the product information
okay and then we want to merge the items
of the user card with the anonymous card
then we want to delete all the currently
existing items in the user card and
replace them for these merged items and
then finally we also want to delete the
anonymous card so that it's empty again
so we have to do a zeroa database
operations now what we have to keep in
mind is what happens if we get an arrow
somewhere in the middle for example what
happens if we delete the items from the
user card but we get an error before we
insert the new items and then the user
card is suddenly emptier this is why we
want to execute all of this in a
transaction a database transaction is a
process where you can do multiple
operations but if one of them fails the
whole transaction will be rolled back
and none of the changes will be applied
and I think pretty much all types of
databases support transactions including
mongodb and to execute the transaction
with Prisma we go below and we write
await
Prisma dot transaction and it starts
with a dollar sign this is the function
name
to this function we can pass an async
function where we execute the actual
transaction and this async function gets
passed in argument which is again a
Prisma client but every operation we
call on this Prisma client and here will
be part of the transaction and in the
documentation they call this TX which I
guess stands for transaction so we add
this argument here and again TX is just
a Prisma client on which we can do our
usual operations now before we set up
this transaction we have to create
another function below outside of merge
Anonymous card into user card
this function will contain the actual
logic that merges the items in these two
cards
so we colored merge card items
and to this function we pass the user
card and the anonymous card right but I
wrote a function in a way that we can
pass any arbitrary number of cards to it
so if you want to merge three cards for
whatever reason in the future then this
will work as well for this we use this
syntax where we start the argument with
three dots this way we create so-called
bar arcs meaning that we can pass as
many of these arguments to this function
as we want
and we cut this arguments card items and
the type of the swag argument
is an array of card items from the
Prisma client
but then we add another array because we
can pass as many of these card item
arrays as we want as I just explained so
this is an array of array of card items
and in here we want to take each entry
of these two cards and combine them
together so if one has a quantity of one
and one has a quantity of two then we
want the quantity of three and if the
anonymous card contains items that are
not in the user card yet then we want to
add them
but instead of writing this out by hand
I just copy paste this here you can
pause the video and type this out this
is nothing new it's just a bit
complicated it uses the reduce function
and for each Loop to go through each of
the card items and then combine the
quantities to be honest I had GitHub
co-pilot write this Logic for me GitHub
copilot in case you don't know is an AI
plugin for vs code it's very useful to
create boilerplate code like this
automatically but all of this still
makes sense so if you go through this
step by step then you will understand
what exactly is happening here again
just take a moment type this out and
then we can continue our transaction
here so in the transaction we want to
check if the user card exists if it
exists we want to merge it with the
anonymous card if it doesn't exist we
want to create a completely newer user
account right
so we check if user account we do this
inside the transaction
and let's also add the ads block white
array so we don't get confused by the
nesting later
if there is a user card we want to use
our merge card items function to merge
the anonymous card with the user card so
we create a const let's call it merged
with a deal
card items
and for this we call our merge card
items function
to which repairs local cards dot items
comma
and user card dot items again since we
made this a one Arc we can pass as many
of these card item arrays as we want
so this now contains the merged card
items
the next step is to delete the existing
items in the user card and then put this
newer merged card items in there instead
so we call a weight TX which is this
Prisma client on which we do the
transaction operations
card item
dot delete menu
and in the filter we Define which ones
we want to delete with this where
value
and in here we want to compare the card
idea
to the user card.id because we want to
delete our card items that belong to
this user card and then put our newer
merge card items in there
So Below we write a wait
TX Dot card item dot create menu
and for the data
we want to pass the merged card items
not merge card items because that's the
name of the function merged card items
which is our new array up here now each
of these merged card items also contains
the idea of this card item in the
database it had before but we are making
new database entries here and we want a
new auto generated idea so we want to
ignore this ID field we only care about
these other three fields
we can do this by mapping these merged
card items
so again in the map function we get past
each item
we add parentheses and curly braces
because these curly braces are not the
block of this function they are the
return value the JavaScript object that
we want to return this is why we have to
wrap this into parentheses and as I said
in here we want to put the card idea
which is user card dot idea
we want to set a product idea to item
dot product idea
and we want to set a quantity to
item.quantity
so now we put this much card items in
here but we ignore the IDS to create a
completely new idea and we also set the
card ID of all of these items to the
user card idea which is important
because the anonymous items didn't have
a card ID before right so we have to set
this here and that's the ID of the card
we found in the database the existing
card
and in the else block
it means we don't have an existing user
card yet and we want to create one
so await
tx.card.create
in here we pass the data as usual curly
braces
we want to set the user ID of this cards
to the user ID we pass to this function
so we pass this as the first argument
again this is a shorthand for writing
user ID column user idea but the value
and the key have the same name so we can
use the short syntax selectors
then we want to put the items in here
items colon and this is a so-called
relation query in Prisma this way we can
create a card in the card collection but
at the same time we can create card
items in the card items collection in
one operation and they will
automatically be connected together by
adding the card idea to these items then
in here we calculate menu to create
serverware card items
and I know that this can look
complicated at first but you just have
to work through this because this is how
you write these database operations
and here we have to pass data again
for which we want to pass
the local card dot items
this time it's not the merged card items
because in this ads block a user card
doesn't exist yet meaning there are no
user card items they are only local card
items but again we want to map this into
the correct structure
again we get past each item and we
return a new JavaScript object for each
of them now since we do this relation
query where we do the operation over the
card and not the card item we don't have
to set the card ID this time this is
automatically handled by this operation
instead this time we only need the
product idea and the quantity and the
card ID will be set automatically
okay and after merging the cards has
completed we want to delete the local
card and also delete the cookie
so we do this below this whole F block
here still inside the transaction
so if user card else and below this else
block
we write a weight TX we are still inside
the transaction
Dot card dot delete
we want to delete the card well
the ID of the card
is the logo card idea the local cards
that we fetched from our cookie
we want to delete this one and then we
want to remove the cookie
which we do with cookies dot set
the same name look a card idea
and then we set this to an empty string
this is how you delete a cookie in xjs
okay maybe let's recap this whole
function one more time we fetch the
local card from this cookie if there is
no local cards then we return because
there is no data that we have to merge
into the user card if there is a local
card then we fetch the user card from
the database if there is no user card in
the database yet then we just have to
create a new one with the items
contained in the logo card and if
there's already a user card and a logo
card then we merge these items and add
them all to the user card and at the end
we delete the local cards because we
don't need it anymore we have merged it
into the users card okay this function
is ready but now the question is where
do we call our merge function here we
want to call dust right after we have
logged in so before the pages open the
merging already happened and as usual
when we see the page all the data is
already displayed correctly and there's
no loading state
so let's go into our next of Route
Handler again
we have the skull back here that will be
called every time we return a session
and Below callbacks we can also add this
events field
and in here we can get cult every time
we did a certain off operation for
example
we have this signed in function here
and this is the perfect place to merge
our cards because this will be called
right after we have signed in but before
we are returned to our home page
we want to make this an async function
because our merge card functions makes
database operations
and we want to destructure this argument
here
we need this user value to get the user
ID
and then here we simply call a weight
merge Anonymous Cards into user account
which expects the user idea
that we can get out of this user this is
the user that just signed in
okay let's try this out
the locked end user has one item in the
cart right now these shoes for 95 bucks
let's sign out
in the anonymous card we have the
headphones and this boss duel
and now when we log in these cards
should be merged and we should have
three items in there let's try this out
sign in to our account
now design and callback is fired which
merges the cards and there we are we
have our user card with the three items
in there and when we log out again we
should see an empty cart because we
cleared the anonymous card this is by
the way also how Amazon handles it let's
try this one more time let's put
something into the anonymous card
maybe two of these plants here and again
this real glitch doesn't happen in
production it only happens in
development
so now we have two of these plants in
here again we log in
and these items will be merged into the
user card
and this eye works isn't this cool now
let's also try if our transaction works
properly as I explained if we have an
error here somewhere inside this
transaction none of these operations
should be applied let's try this out by
throwing an error here at the very end
of the transaction
throw error
test
just for a moment obviously we will
remove this ladder so now I do the same
process again
I log out I add this card to the
shopping cart
but now when we log in and execute our
merge function it will fail because of
this error but the error is thrown at
the very end after all these operations
but since these operations are part of a
transaction they shouldn't be applied
when this error occurs within the
transaction so let's see
we log in again
we should see this error in the console
that is error test
our user card still only has five items
because this merging failed
and this one item is still in our
Anonymous card so the website still
works but these cards are not merged but
they are also not left in an
inconsistent state so this is a really
professional setup
all right let's not forget to remove
this error here maybe I will leave this
as a comment
one more thing I want to mention is
whenever we fetch cookies like we do
when we either get the anonymous card
or also inside get server session then
the route that uses this function is
automatically dynamically rendered this
is important because when we show the
card of the user this data is different
for each individual user right so we
don't want to Cache this page on our
backend and serve the exact same page to
each user every user has their own card
but we don't have to configure this
cache ourselves because again whenever
we get cookies which we do here but
which is also done inside get server
session then the page is rendered
dynamically automatically so it fetches
new data whenever we open the page and
it's not cached between users this is
where we don't have to add revalidate 0
to our cart page for example this
happens automatically because we
retrieve the card here and to verify
this we can actually build the project
with npm run built
which takes a moment this builds this
project for production mode
and here we can see from these icons how
these pages are rendered and cached
so this Lambda symbol here means that
the page is not cached instead it's
created every time the page is opened
and when we look at the cut route here
we see this Lambda symbol so this page
is not statically cached which is good
okay this was a tough part but I think
we learned a lot and in the next section
we will Implement pagination here for
our front page so that we don't show our
products at once
okay so to have enough items that we can
actually page in it
let's go to the ads product page again
which now requires authentication that's
good
and then let's add a bunch of newer
products but let's do so in a loop so
that we don't have to repeat this
process like 50 times let's go to the
add product page code and then just for
this one operation I will put a loop in
here so let's say
for
I
and let's just put I don't know 50 items
in here
and then I want to repeat this process
here
and create the exact same item in the
database 50 times just so that we can
later see our full page generation bar
with many pages in action so let's save
this then we need an image again as
usual we take this from unsplash I'm
going to use this Clone Trooper here
because what would be more fitting
for 50 items with the exact same data
and then a clone trooper
so I paste the image URL here
called this clone trooper
description this is a cooler
controller bar we have many of them of
course this data here doesn't matter and
the price will be I don't know 19.99
now we should execute this in this Loop
and add the same item 50 times right
so this will take a moment to complete
okay let's refresh the page
and now we have this Clone Trooper in
here 50 times
let's also remove the for loop again
because obviously we don't want to keep
this
and then we want to paginate this front
page here because if we have a lot of
items in our database we don't want to
show all of them at once we want to show
them in pages so let's go into our
project and set up a pagination bar
we will put this into the components
folder
because you will likely reuse this in
different places
pagination bar dot TSX
as usual The Styling of this component
is coming from Daisy UI
this is how it looks
and in this fire we export a default
function which we also call pagination
Bar
and this component also needs props
pagination bar props
we need the current page so that we can
highlight this element in the pagination
bar and also make it not clickable
which will be a number
and we of course need a total number of
pages
so that we know how many items to show
in this pagination bar
then we add this propstone here
and destructure them
current page total pages
now in this pagination bar I don't want
to show all pages at once because if we
have 100 Pages for example then we don't
want to show all the numbers from 1 to
100 here right we only want to show a
subset of these numbers for this we will
write some logic that calculates these
page numbers you can just follow along
we create a const Max page that's the
largest page number that will be shown
in our pagination bar
we assign this to math.min which Returns
the smallest of the values we pass to
this function
to this we pass total Pages comma and
then math.nex which is the opposite of
math.min
and here repairs current Page Plus 4
comma 10.
so the max page will be the current Page
Plus 4. so if we are on page 13 for
example the largest page number will be
17. however if we are on page 1 for
example then there will be no pages to
the left of page 1 right because there
are no smaller pages in this case I want
to show all the page numbers all the way
up to 10 otherwise the pagination bar
would be very small also if there is no
current Page Plus 4 because we are on
page 17 for example and there are only
18 total Pages then we want to use the
total pages instead this is where we
wrap this into math.min I know this is a
bit complicated at first but you can
just play around with this and see how
this behaves
then we also create a const Min page
for which we use nav dot Max
comma
math dot min
and to math.min we pass current page -5
or next page minus nine like this
again this calculates an appropriate
value for the Min page that is not
smaller than one and I just came up with
this by playing around and zero what
looks good
and then we want to generate page items
from the Min page all the way up to the
next page we do this in a loop so we
create another for Loop
let's call the index page
we start at Min page so we replace the
zero for Min page
entry one renders until page is less
than or equal to the max page
and then inside this Loop we want to add
page items to an array so above the loop
let's create this array
cons numbered page items
this will be of type jsx element array
because this contains jsx elements
and we initialize this with an empty
array
and then in the loop for each round we
can say numbered page items dot push to
put a new element in here
and each page item will be a link
so we use a next link here
the text of the link will be the current
page number which is the index of the
loop
and then we configure the link itself
so
we add an href
and what we do is we navigate to the
current page but we append this page URL
query param with a question mark page
equals
plus the current page number
so this adds this page query param to
the current destination and we can read
the page from the URL in our server
component
and then since we are in the loop we
also have to add a key to each element
for which we can just use the page
number
and then we also want to add the class
name to each link
we make this an expression with curly
braces and add a back text string in
here
the first class we need for all of these
items is this join item class which is
used in Daisy uif for these pagination
bar items
and we also use the button class BTN
then we put an expression in here with a
dollar design and curly braces and what
I want to do is I want to disable the
currently selected page item so that we
can't even click it so it has a
different styling but we will also not
make it clickable
we can do this with a class but we want
to apply this class conditionally
so in this expression we check if the
current page
is equal to the page of this item
then question mark ternary operator
we want to apply another class in
quotation marks
we want to apply BTN active which
changes the highlighting color of this
item
and then I also want to make this
element unclickable for which we can use
the pointer minus events minus none
class
which is coming from Tailwind
then we add the second half of the
ternary operator colon if this item is
not the current page we don't want to
add an additional class so we just pass
an empty string here
okay and then we create the pagination
bar itself in the return statement
so in here we put a div
to which we add the class name join
that's the counterpart of join item this
connects these items visually
and in the stuff we want to render
our numbered page items right
let's see how this looks let's go to our
front page and before we actually fetch
the count of pages and items we have
let's just hard code This pagination Bar
in here for now just to see how it looks
so we have our pagination bar
let's set the current page to three and
the total pages to earn a large number
and then see how this looks
there it is let's Center this on the
screen by adding some class names to the
outer diff
we add Flex
color
and item Center which would send
everything including the patronation bar
so we see the pages from 1 to 10 if I
set the current page to 13.
you can see the responsive page numbers
in action now the smallest value is 8
the largest one is 17 and we never show
all 99 Pages at once because that would
be too many but our pagination bar is
still not fully responsive if the screen
width is too small
then this will not all fit on the screen
so let's make this responsive by
switching to a different kind of view
what I want to do is when the screen is
small I want to switch to this kind of
pagination bar where we just have the
current page and a button for left and
right
so let's go back into our
pagination bar component and what we can
do is we can hide this div on small
screens or rather on very small screens
by setting this to Hidden by default and
then on the SM breakpoint which are
small screens and larger
we want to set the display back to a
block so we show it on this screen size
and larger and on this very small screen
it's very hides these page numbers we
want to show a different element instead
and to put multiple elements into this
return block we can wrap this into such
a fragment
because there always has to be one
parent element and there's no reason to
make this a div because only one of
these will be shown a diff would work as
well as the wrapper but I think a
fragment is more semantically correct So
Below the first diff we put executive
and here we add the class name join
again
on gravy small screens we set this to
display block by default and on small
screens and larger this one will be
hidden so only one of these two will be
shown depending on the screen size and
in here we put these elements from this
UI I just showed you earlier so we have
this left button
which we only want to show
if current page is larger than one
because otherwise there is no previous
page that we can navigate to right
so if the current page is larger than
one we want to render a link
The Edge ref again will point to a
question mark page equals
and we append
current page -1 and we wrap this into
parentheses
and this link needs the same join item
and BTN classes as we used for our
numbered page items
so we add the class name here as well
BTN and join item
we close this link tag and as the text
we use this left Arrow here which I just
copied from Days UI I have no idea how
to enter this in a normal keyboard but I
will link this pagination bar again in
the video description below so you can
copy it from there but you can also just
use any other icon here
okay then we want the button for the
current page right and then this right
arrow
zor below this expression here where we
checked current page larger than one
we add a button this doesn't have to be
a link because this will be disabled
anyway it will not be clickable
so to this button we add the class names
again join item
BTN
and pointer events none to make this
unclickable
and this was a page
and the current page number
then below the white Arrow
we check
if current page is less than
total Pages because if we are on the
last page
then we don't need the right button in
here again we put the link just like
this one so let's actually copy this
just that we wanna go to a current Page
Plus One
and the text in here will be a right
arrow
okay let's save this and see how this
looks
so this is the full pagination bar
and if I make this small enough
eventually it turns into this pagination
bar
but we can't try it out yet because we
haven't set up pagination here yet so
let's do that next
let's go to the front page which is the
page TSX in the app folder
first of all we need to read the current
page out of the URL because the
pagination bar
adds this as a UL param right
so in our page here we can get the
search params from the props for this we
create an interface
called home props
and in here we add this search params
field and you have to spell it exactly
like this in camera case because this is
how we get the search params out of the
URL in xjs we need this exact prop name
and this will contain an object with the
different search params and in here we
expect our page which will be a string
this number page is coming from
the pagination bar because this is how
we are cult this search param value here
this has to match
and then we can destructure this page
here in the component
home props and this is actually not the
page yet
it contains the search params and the
search params contain the page so this
is how we destructure this
what we can also do is we can give this
a default value of 1 like this as a
string because such params are strings
this way we have a page number to work
with even if no query param is added to
the URL and in this case of course we
want to load the first page
so next we have to turn this page param
into a number
so we create the const current page
and then we call Path int
to which we pass the page param and even
if we don't pass one it will be Z to A
one as the fallback value then we also
need to define a page size and let's
store this value in a variable as well
that's good practice because this way we
avoid magic numbers where we just have
numbers in our codes that we might not
remember what the meaning was
so let's create a const page size and
let's set this to this you can also make
this larger if you want to deploy this
app but for testing purposes a small
page size is easier to work with and
then we also want to create a number
for the hero item count the hero item is
this element here at the top
we have to take this into account when
we paginate our results because we will
only show this on the first page and
again to avoid magic numbers in our code
I store this value in a variable as well
and maybe in the future you want to have
more than one of these hero items then
you have to change this number then we
need the total number of items in our
database so that we can calculate the
largest page so we create a const total
item count and we can get this through
Prisma
by calling a wedge
Prisma dot product because this is what
we want to count
and then we have discount function here
which Returns the total number of
products in our database
and from this we can calculate the
number of total Pages we have right
so we created const
total pages
equals
this would be a total item count divided
by a page size
but since we have this additional hero
item on the first page we subtract this
from the total item count so minus zero
item count
of course we have to wrap this part into
parentheses because division takes
precedence over subtraction and this can
return a decimal value so it can return
something like 4.5 pages but we always
want to round this up because if we have
four and a half page then we need five
pages in our pagination bar right so we
wrap this into another pair of
parentheses
and before it we add math.co
which rounds this number we pass in here
up so 4.5 for example will be rounded up
to a 5. okay now we have the number of
pages and now we want to modify our
Prisma query to only return the current
page
so we keep the order by we still want to
order this with the newest product at
the top
and after this we add the skip field
where we can Define how many items you
want to skip because if we are on page 2
we want to skip all the items of the
first page so we want to skip current
page minus one
so if we are on Page tour we want to
skip one fully page that's the first
page
times the page size right
now again since we have this hero item
on the first page we want to add
something to this page size
in parentheses we want to check if the
current page is equal to one if we are
on the first page then we don't want to
skip any additional items because we
show the hero item so after a question
mark we write 0. but if we are not on
the first page we want to skip one which
is the hero item actually we don't want
to skip one we want to skip here or item
count first of all this makes it more
readable because again we avoid this
magic number but this can also now adapt
to a two or more hero items
so now we have defined how many items we
want to skip after this we add another
comma
and also adds this take field which
tells Prisma how many items to return
for this page this is obviously the page
size but again we have to account for
this hero item
so we add plus if the current page is
the first page
question mark
then we want to add hero item count to
the patreon size otherwise we don't want
to add this
okay now we have all our values here so
we can use them down here on our
pagination bar
but I want to render this pagination bar
only if we have more than one page
otherwise it's a bit unnecessary
so we check if total pages is greater
than one only then we want to render
This pagination Bar
then for current page
we pass the current page that we passed
from the URL
and for total Pages we pass the total
pages that we calculated
so now when we save this we only see six
items and we are on page one right
what happens if we click Page tour we
still render our hero item at the top so
down here we only have five items now so
we want to hide this hero item if we are
not on page one so let's scroll up to
our hero item
right here
and render this only
if current page
is equal to 1.
to Amazon science and we wrap this all
around this hero item
but now we still only have five items
here because we are sliced the products
and we remove the first item that's the
one we were showing in the hero item so
what we do is
we remove this whole part
and instead we add parentheses
and here we check if current page is
equal to 1
then we want a map from
products.slice.1 as we did before
but if we are not on the first page
colon we want to take the whole products
array we don't want to remove the first
item if we are on page 2 upwards so now
when we save this we see six items
let's refresh the page just to make sure
that the changes are applied correctly
on page three we still see the same six
items
and eventually we should get to our
old items here these ones
all of them show six items except for
the first page which shows this
additional hero item at the top so this
works correctly
and the currently selected page is
content
in the URL
this is basically how you can maintain
state in server components server
components don't have real estate they
can't use your state but they can put
information in the URL like the page
number and when you use search params in
a server component like we are doing
here then this page is automatically
dynamically rendered meaning every time
we open this page or refresh it we get
the latest data and it's not cached this
is because next.js recognizes that we
are reading the search params which are
Dynamic nextges can't know in advance
which search params we are passing here
for example it can't know which page we
are trying to open so if we added newer
products to our database they will
always be shown here even if we don't
compile the project again in production
this has the same effect as adding
export const we validate equal 0 which I
explain in my next.js beginner course
this also makes this page dynamically
rendered but again search param status
automatically and this is also to be
heavier we want here usually because
when you add new products to your
database you usually want to show these
changes immediately right okay so our
page is already very professional next I
want to implement this search
functionality here
so the search field itself already works
right we have already implemented this
so if I search for Trooper for example
we get redirected to the search page and
we add this query as a query param we
just haven't set up the page itself yet
so let's do that next so we create a new
page
in the app directory first we have to
create a folder
search that's the relative URL
that we navigate to and then here we put
the page TSX as usual
and then we export the default function
which we call search page
and just like on the front page we want
to get the search params out of the URL
because this contains the search query
so we create an interface search page
props
and here again we need the search params
with this exact spelling
and this time in here we expect the
query which is a string
and then here we want to get the search
programs
out of the props
and out of these search params we want
to get the query
and then we want to fetch these results
out of the database
so we turn this into an async function
this is just a normal server component
and in here we create the const products
and call await Prisma
dot product dot find menu we want to
return mailable products
and then we add our filter here
where colon curly braces
and I want to search in both the name
and the description of the product so we
can use this or operator in our
uppercase to which we can pass an array
with multiple queries and only one of
these queries has to match
so we add them between curly braces
first we want to search in the name of
the product so we write Name colon
curly braces and then we have this
contents comparator here
we want to find this if the name
contains the query and the query is the
search query that we get out of the URL
and then after contains query we add the
comma
and we set the mode to insensitive which
is a string this makes the search case
insensitive so it doesn't matter if our
query contains uppercase or lowercase
letters this will always find the same
results then we add a comma at the end
and we duplicate this line to add
another entry to our or array here
just that this time we want to search in
the description and again since this is
wrapped into or only one of these has to
match
and I also want to order these results
so after the wear down here
we add order buyer colon curly braces
again we want to order by idea in
descending order again the ID contains a
timestamp
so we have our data and now we want to
render this in the UI
first of all I want to check if
products.length
is equal to zero
then we want to return a div
that says
no products
found
and I want to send that this text on the
screen so I add a class name text sender
which again is coming from Tailwind
so this is an early return in case there
are no products that match this query
if there are products
we want to return them in the list so
below we add another return statement
we wrap this intuitive
inside this diff we want to map our
products
products.map as usual we get past each
product
and we want to render the same product
cards that we also use on the front page
so to this product card we have to pass
the product
and the key
with the product idea
we also want to install the script
properly so we can copy these class
names here from the front page product
card grid
except for the mi41 we can copy this you
can also type them out by hand if you
prefer
and we add them to this div here
so let's save this and see how this
looks
we are still on the search page right
let's refresh this just to be sure
and here are our results you can
paginate them as well if you want I
didn't bother implementing pagination
here but you already know how this works
let's search for something else like
store and it finds our bar stool of
course you can customize the search to
your preferences okay I also want to add
a title to this page and I want this
title to depend on the search query
so to make this dynamic
we export the function generate meta
data again the spelling has to be exact
as we already know this can take the
same props as the page itself
so we pass the search page props and get
a query out of here
this function will
return
metadata this time we don't have to wrap
this into a promise because this will
not be a fetched asynchronously we don't
need to do a database operation here
we just want to use the query itself in
the title so I want to set the title
tool
back text string search column
then I put the query in here
and then our usual Dash
flomas on at the end
yeah of course there should be no colon
after return
so now this says search colon then the
query we typed in and then flowmason
really cool
so feature-wise our app is finished but
we still have to deploy it and there are
some additional steps we have to take
but there's one other thing I want to
change first and this will require us to
implement a Prisma extension Prisma
extension is a brand new feature that
just became available and this is a very
interesting topic that you don't want to
skip here so make sure to watch this
tutorial all the way to the end
the fact that we can create Anonymous
shopping carts is really cool but one
problem this creates is that we might
accumulate a lot of abandoned shopping
carts in our database because a user can
create an anonymous shopping cart but
then delete the cookie for example or
maybe they were using the incognito tab
which doesn't store cookies across
sessions and once this cookie is deleted
there is no connection to the shopping
cart in the database anymore and also no
way for the user to retrieve it anymore
instead the next time they add an item
to their cards they create a completely
newer shopping cart so it might be a
good idea to delete these abandoned
shopping carts from the database from
time to time for this we can check the
updated ads timestamp of the card
together with the user idea we can for
example say okay if a card doesn't
belong to a use also if it doesn't have
a user idea and it hasn't been updated
in a while then we want it deleted and
then you can also go through the card
items and delete all card items and that
belong to the card that you just deleted
the problem is right now when we update
our card items in our server actions the
updated add timestamp of the card is not
updated because we are doing these
updates directly over the card item
model now we can change this and use a
relation query as we already did before
we use a relation query
in our merge cut function down here
where we create a card and the card
items in one operation this is a
so-called relation query because we
create card items over this card model
here so we create two models at the same
time in our server actions we can do the
same instead of doing the operation on
the card item we change this query so
let's start with card item dot delete in
the server action file of the shopping
cart page so instead of card item delete
we can write await Prisma
and do it over the card model but we
don't want to delete a card we want to
delete the card items so on the card
itself we are doing an update
parentheses curly braces
we have fetched the cards that we are
updating
so we can say we want to update the
cartwheel
ideal
is equal to the card idea
and then we add this data field
that contains the actual update values
and in here we want to update the items
which are the card items that belong
to the card with this idea so this will
find the items with this card idea in
the card items collection and in here we
can add the delete operation
and an idea colon
article and car dot idea article in card
is what we've filtered up here so this
now does the same thing as this
operation down here it's a bit longer
but now this delete operation is routed
over our card model and this later
allows us to update the updated add
timestamp of the shopping cart of which
we change the card items to the latest
date so that we always know when was the
last time we made changes to the items
of this card so now we also delete this
operation down here we don't need it
anymore and we replace the other two as
well so here we are updating card items
to do it over the card we write a rate
Prisma
Dot cards dot update again
we use this wear filter
and for the data
we pass items colon curly braces again
this time we want to do an update
operation
again we need our filter in here well
idea
is article and cut dot idea
again comma and again data with the
update values
and we want to update the quantity just
like we did down here
so let's delete this operation as well
because we have replaced it
and one more below
again a weight Prisma Dot cards dot
update
again with the same filter
data
this time we're going to create card
items
so again items colon curly braces create
and then they create body which contains
the same values as down here the product
idea
and the quantity
and then we delete this operation
now let's also do the same in the auto
server actions file where we have these
two operations let's replace them as
well
so a weight Prisma Dot card dot update
again we paste our wear filter and add
the data here
we want to update the items
and on the items we want to do an update
operation
with the same filters as shown here so
we can copy this part
and paste it here
and then we delete this old operation
and one more
then we should be done
await Prisma Dot cards dot update
where the card idea
is this one
and then data
items
and in the future you want to do all
your card item updates over the card
model to keep this updated as timestamp
up to date
and in here we write create
and then we can copy paste
this payload here
and delete this operation
let's save it
or there's one more in the card TS file
in the lib folder
we have these two operations here but
since we do them one after another in a
transaction it's enough if we make one
of them an update on the card model so
let's keep card item delete menu and
replace card item create menu
so I wait this time it's this TX Prisma
client
dot cut dot update
where
the idea is the user card
dot idea
that's the one we are updating
and the local card gets deleted
data colon we want to update the card
items
we want to execute the create many
operation and you get Auto completion
here by the way this helps you with
coming up with these operations and then
we want to copy this part down here
but we can delete the line with the card
idea since we are doing this operation
over the cut model this will be set
automatically in this nested update
and then we can delete
to create menu operation below
so now we are doing all our card item
updates over the card model
unfortunately this still doesn't update
the updated ads timestamp because this
by default is only updated if we
actually make changes to a card's
document so to a value in here there is
an active discussion on GitHub about
updating this updated ad timestamp of
the parent document when we do a nested
query like we are doing here so in the
future there might be a setting that you
can change to enable this so that the
updated ads timestamp of the card is
updated automatically even when we only
update the card items but right now this
doesn't work yet and we have to find our
own workaround now one way to handle
this would be to just add
the updated add timestamp
to our update operation and set this to
our dates dot now to the current
timestamp but of course this is very
tedious because we have to remember to
do this in every single update operation
and we might forget this somewhere now a
solution I came up with to fix this is
to use a Prisma client extension this is
a brand new feature available for Prisma
client extensions allow us to hook into
our queries for example and then do
something in there which will be
executed every time we do an operation
for this let's go into our
prisma.ts file where we initialize our
Prisma client and then let's use such an
extension to automatically update the
updated ads timestamp whenever we do an
update operation on the card so what we
do is we remove this export from the
default Prisma client
and we rename it with f2l to press my
base and down here we also assign
prisoner base to Global for Prisma
but the Prisma client that we want to
export from this file is the extended
one so below we write export const
Prisma
then we take our Prisma base
and call this dollar sign extends a
function on there
with which we can create a client
extension in here we have this query
here with which we can hook into the
query operations
so colon curly braces we want to hook
into the queries of the cards so card
colon curly braces
and in here we want to make a change to
the update query because update is what
we use in all our server actions when we
make changes to the card items
and this argument here should be an
async function so we write async update
parentheses
curly braces
and in here we can destructure arguments
and other competition should help us we
need the arcs
and the query
the arcs contain the actual body of the
update so the data that we are passing
and to this we want to add the updated
Earth timestamp
so in here we can make changes to
arcs.data
then we assign this to a JavaScript
object in here we spread the existing
arcs.data to keep all the update
operations in here
comma and additionally we also want to
update the updated as timestamp
and we want to set this to a newer date
which gives us the current timestamp
and then below we have to return the
query
to which we pass these updated arcs
okay and this is how we create a Prisma
client extension let's format this let's
save it and then our route Handler here
complaints
that's our next off Route Handler
it doesn't recognize our extended client
as a Prisma client anymore they will
probably fix this typing in the future
again this is a very new feature but we
can get around those
by casting this to a Prisma client from
Express my slash client like this
this way we tell type script relax this
is a normal Prisma client again in the
future it might not be necessary to use
a client extension if they add an option
to automatically update the updated ads
timestamp even if we don't make a change
to the cards document itself but right
now we have to go this detour so let's
try this out
in our database we have this one card
right the updated ad timestamp is
currently still the same as the created
ads timestamp because we haven't changed
anything in this document even though we
added and we updated card items the
updated ads timestamp still has the
default value but now with our new
changes when I make an update to the
card
this updated AD timestamp should change
so I change the quantity of an item for
example
let's update this and you can see the
newer timestamp let's try it one more
time maybe let's add a new item
a clone trooper
and again right now this is 650 18.
and after refreshing this this updates
to the current time so now what you can
do is you can set up a current job so a
task that runs after a certain time
interval regularly for this you can use
vessel Crown jobs because we will deploy
this project to Brazil and this way you
can execute a route Handler so a server
endpoint from time to time which then
checks all your Anonymous cards it
checks when they were last updated and
if they haven't been updated for a while
it deletes the card and the card items
that belong to this card and the cards
that have a user idea belong to a user
so you usually don't want to delete them
at all because they are tied to a user
account we won't implement this in this
tutorial you can figure this out
yourself you can also keep the abandoned
card items in the database if you want I
just wanted to show you how you can
update the updated ad timestamp so that
you know which cards to delete
okay now it's time to deploy our project
to production so that we can actually
open our website over the internet and
as usual the easiest way to deploy an
xjs project is via Versa which is a
hosting provider and also the company
that created and maintains next.js so as
you can imagine this is really optimized
to deploy an xjs project and all these
features like server components and
server actions will just work to deploy
our project we first have to push it to
GitHub you can do this right in vs code
over the source control tab here you
want to push your project to a GitHub
repository this repository can be
private doesn't have to be public and
then you want to sign up on the sale and
connect it to your GitHub account
because then we can just click on ADD
newer and add a new project
and this shows us all our projects on
our GitHub account right now I'm logged
into coding and flow and here I can just
click on import and add the next.js
eCommerce project however before we
deploy this we have to make a few more
preparations first of all we go back
into our project
and open the package.json
here we have to add a post and style
script this is described in the Prisma
documentation otherwise if we try to
deploy this project on bezel we will get
an error this is explained here it
happens because of the way that they
catches the Prisma client we have to add
this post install script here
in our package.json so this goes into
the scripts block
like this
then we want to push this change to our
main branch so add
Prisma
post install script
commit and push
then we also go into our Atlas backend
go to the network access tab where right
now we only allow connections from our
localhost right so we click on ADD IP
address and in order to be able to
connect from Brazil we have to allow
access from anywhere which adds this
zero IP address because the cell uses
serverless functions we don't have our
own server machine with a single IP
address and Status IP address can change
so we have to allow access from anywhere
but our database is still protected by
the password so this doesn't mean anyone
can make changes to our database we
still need the correct password
so we confirmed this then let's go back
to Brazil
and import our project here so we click
on import it automatically recognizes
that this is an xjs project
we don't have to change any build and
output settings but we need to add our
environment variables
so in here we put the same and for
variables that we have in our DOT end
file
the database URL which is the same as
here
then we click on ADD and then we can add
another one
Google client idea
add
client Secret
we don't have a next half URL yet
because we don't know our URL in advance
the cell actually gives us a Freer URL
under dot the cell dot app but I don't
know this one in advance so I'm gonna
add a placeholder here
HTTP colon slash slash
and I'm just gonna write placeholder.com
I think this will work we will later
replace this for the actual URL we get
from USA
and the next of the secret which again
is just any random
combination of characters so I just type
in a new one here
click on ADD
and then
we click on deployer
and hope that this works
this will take a minute or so
that's me in the corner
that's me and the spot light oh and it
worked nice congratulations you just
deployed a new project to Brazil and we
even get confetti okay let's click on
continue to dashboard
and then we get different domains for
Freon and we have a separate domain for
each commit basically that's this one
here
we have a domain for this main branch
and then we have this domain here which
basically just references the project so
as you can see it has the project name
next.js e-commerce recording coding and
floor dotzel.deb let's open this one
here because this one will stay the same
even if we deploy more changes
we copy this URL
because we still have to edit as the
redirect URL to our Google Cloud project
so let's edit our oauth client
and add this new redirect URL with our
desire domain
and then the same endpoint here after
the slash
because this is what next off requires
we saved us
and now we should be able to log in on
our bezel domain as well so let's see if
this works we are still locked out right
now let's see if we can add an item to
the card
this seems to work
let me close the website
and open it again
and see if the card is still intact
refresh the page this seems to work
let's take a look into our database
where we should find a newer card
without a user idea that's this one here
and we should have the same card idea in
our cookie
so let's check the application tab
and here is the local card idea that
ends with 597 so this works just like in
development let's see if we can log into
our Google account
yeah and it works and it merged this new
Clone Trooper into our shopping cart and
whenever you make a change to your
project you only have to push these
changes to the main branch and they will
automatically be deployed by Brazil you
don't even have to click anything every
change that you push to the main branch
will automatically be deployed and then
a minute later it will be available on
your website let's also check if the
social media preview works for this we
can use this social share preview.com
website
and here we can add
our domain
and then see if we see our open craft
image
so flomazon we make your wallet cry and
there's our OG image
as I explained
this is this open craft image in our app
folder I added this to the starting
project but for a single product page
on slash products slash idea
we use the product image as the OG image
so let's see if this works as well so I
go to a single product
I copy this URL
and then we should see our Clone Trooper
instead
Clone Trooper flomas on and the
description of the product and this is
what you will see if you post a link to
our website on Facebook Twitter or any
of these social media websites really
cool congratulations you built your own
Ecommerce website and deployed it to
production now you could buy a domain
for example a real domain connected to
your project and then put Amazon out of
business if this tutorial was any
helpful please do me a favor and leave a
like on this video this shows me that
there's more interest into turrets like
this and also leave a comment what kind
of project tutorials you want to see in
the future and lastly I would be happy
if you'll follow me on Twitter because
there are a release regular little
coding tips that I figure out while I'm
preparing these projects my Twitter
handle is coding and Flow and then I
wish you a nice rest of the day happy
coding take care